this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by tushy upstart and superhero
stuff you should know
more on that later let's get into the do
the honeydew
with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we
are over here
doing it at the night pants studios i'm
ryan sickler as always ryan sickler.com
sign up for the email list ryan sickle
on all social media
uh patreon get over to the patreon sign
up for the honeydew with y'all
um submit at honeydewpodcast gmail.com
i've had some crazy stories crazy
stories you guys are sharing
uh it's been a lot of fun also make sure
you subscribe to the youtube channel as
well
and uh the honeydewpodcast.com is a
website it's where you find all the
social media links follow along there
the merch
night pants nation night shorts nation i
can't thank y'all enough you guys are
killing it out there
you look good too god damn it's good
merch i know it's good merch you guys
tell me it's good merch
uh and if you live in la i always uh
mention i got the love for the santa
monica music center here where i record
uh they have online classes you can get
them from real los angeles musicians all
right so go to santa monicamusic.com use
the code honeydew they will waive the
registration fee
and give you a free lesson when you sign
up for a package now
that all the business is out of the way
uh you know what we do over here we
highlight the low lights i always say
these are the stories behind the
storytellers
and uh ladies and gentlemen it is great
to have back first time here in
the night pants studios ladies and
gentlemen joey diaz
all right you look good guys
you brought me so the podcast
association has no b
for this none we're [ __ ] doing our
thing number one
i want to thank jimmy's seafood and
baltimore
[ __ ] straight up gangsters shout out
to jimmy's seafood baltimore
they sent me the dip i had the crab
cakes yesterday you know you got to help
out
every week i try to throw something
somewhere and i ordered a couple crab
cakes next you know
i'm getting two boxes so i want to thank
i want you to let you know to reach out
to uh
jimmy's seafood and [ __ ] order
something yeah they do free today's
[ __ ] crab cakes [ __ ] phillips this is
a cracker
fill up with his brother to suck my dick
okay it's jimmy's seafood when it comes
to crab cakes
and the [ __ ] stuff you see ranch
around
it's so good and people say how much
does he pay up nothing he's a friend
we've gotten to be friends all because
of the rogan podcast
that's it he sent me a package i'm like
this guy and i do
my shows there now he's a it's a great
family business if you're looking for
the best seafood crab cakes for sure in
the country jimmy seafood baltimore
maryland all right
um tommy yeah pull that mic up because
that visor you sat a little quiet
on that visor so i'm all right i'm yeah
there you go
tell me about your new patreon i wish i
would have one of these when i was
snorting coke
outside you could [ __ ] just put it
around
forget the patreon let's get to the
[ __ ] story all right patreon so last
time
we sat down uh it was the worst year of
your life we did
all of 1984. so let's just start
wherever january 1985.
when we left off last time i was pulling
out of the hotel with mr terranova and
the drug dealer joel was
exactly right and i pulled out and uh
this is story this is funny because i
was talking to theo vaughn about it
what the [ __ ] is wrong with me what
happened was this
uh mr t was a good guy he was my one of
my high school teachers but
great guy he had gotten clean
so when i saw him he's like look at the
[ __ ] shape of you
you look [ __ ] terrible you gotta go
to a rehab you gotta get it together he
goes i got a friend that runs uh
a detox it's like all right
let me think about this so i owed so
much money i was in so much trouble i go
how bad will the detox be
for 10 days i go in there he goes taking
no feature
they feed you like a [ __ ] king you'll
love it so as we pulled away
i had uh you know 2 000 bucks
maybe and we were headed to the detox
it was new year's day i get to the detox
i got a two-week waiting period why is
because everybody gets clean
people went right from the [ __ ]
boozer straight to the [ __ ] detox
you're either going to the gym it looks
like it's what it got it was like
[ __ ]
uh corona it was like people were
walking past me and stretches and [ __ ]
like
that's it they had had enough they were
out like they
i walked in they're like you walked in
look at these guys they're [ __ ]
people like swatting flies and [ __ ] i
saw him i saw him
you know i was in colombia people were
[ __ ] up
it was the end of 84. so he goes why
don't we do this
when can you get him into the detox and
the guy goes ah
i don't know what day it was he goes i
don't know maybe next week one day
leave your number and we'll definitely
put them on the priority list
so i'm like what we only want to do is
walk come over and you can stay at my
house for a few days
so i went to his house he was in the
program
i think the first three days i just
slept i just basically got up
to eat dinner and i'll go back to bed so
did he just assume like sort of a coach
role
for the week or was he keeping an eye on
you or were you
free to [ __ ] up if you were gonna [ __ ]
up you know what
you know what and then he had he had two
kids at the time like
four and two wow and he let you stay
and his wife and nice they had a bedroom
upstairs
a little bedroom and i just stayed in
there
like with a blanket i brought and
a pillow and just shivered for a few
days
like i was just shaking not from the
detox of the drugs
but just of what i had been through for
those five or six months
you know i had been through a lot it was
like seven months of getting pounded
like just getting pounded like people
are right now yeah like right now
it's six or seven months people are
getting pounded you know on top of
covert they lost their job
their their mother-in-law died they
can't go
to the house you know it's one of those
type of years where
you just sleep for three [ __ ] days so
i
basically slept and he goes listen the
guy called
he'll have a bed for you in a few days
and then we were talking and something
happened where
he said you know i can't [ __ ] believe
it i'm coming i'm kind of light on the
mortgage
and i know how much you like and he goes
like eight bills or something something
where
like why don't i give you the 800 and
just detox here with you
because he was already taking me to
meetings you know so i started going to
meetings with them
[ __ ] hilarious
what the [ __ ] you're hearing like by the
fourth day i was already shaking for a
line
emotionally i was beat up and i'm going
to these meetings and these people
you know a meeting in hollywood and the
meeting in new jersey
is too different i got a message i'm
going to feel that
when you go to a meeting in hollywood
everybody's like you know huggy doggy
i remember people getting insulted in
the meetings in jersey like
some guy comes in like yeah when i drank
i used to drink
like a bottle a day and people like
about the day go [ __ ] yourself
you [ __ ] we would do it i would walk
into a bar and tell the bartender give
me the bottle no ice cubes i didn't even
drink [ __ ] ice you [ __ ] [ __ ]
see they told me right away first off
you want to complete these meetings
you got to smoke if you're going to be
sober in these meetings it's not going
to work unless you smoke
cigarettes or weed of cigarettes like
you might as well start smoking now
so i tried it but by then i was still an
anti-cigarette
i was like i can't do it and then i
figure i went to like
two weeks of meetings maybe a week of
meetings
and miami vice was coming back that
friday night
and i made up a story i go listen friday
night
i got to do something i got to go see a
guy about a [ __ ]
job and he's like job i go yeah this guy
wants to hire me i don't know let me go
talk to him
and i remember again he lived in crescal
new jersey
i remember from going to the supermarket
i kept saying the bus is going by
that means all those buses go to new
york so i ran up to the corner
it was [ __ ] freezing i
ran into the city got a nickel bag of
weed
like i hadn't smoked in like nine days
uh that had been the longest ever since
i started smoking
and i remember it was freezing out and
rolling the joint on the platform
at port authority on 181st street it's
outside
yeah you're outside there's no [ __ ]
you're outside
there's maybe like four people shivering
and i'm like
[ __ ] rolling this joint with frozen
fingers
i smoked it i walked in there was the
episode with glenn frye
smuggler's blues and t
was going crazy look at this this is
[ __ ] tremendous
did i ever tell you when i went to
columbia i started coke with the [ __ ]
galindo family i mean he was just going
off
so we're [ __ ] howling so i got this
job
uh i stayed with him i stayed clean
i stayed with him all right so hold on i
want to make that clear like so
because i hear about a lot of aaa clean
some people say
they use marijuana some say i don't know
i hear you for you was a little bit of
weed i'm saying clean for me at that
time was we
a little bit of wheat just wait and then
i figured out that if you smoked weed
and went to an a meeting
it was really a party i'll bet that one
that's a party so
i'm like listen i don't know about you
i'm not a boozer
but i love my marijuana he's like jesus
[ __ ] christ you kids
you can't do the program i have cocked i
go i'm not using coke
and i'm not drinking that's what got me
here reefer don't bother nobody that
doesn't so i would
take two hits off a joint and go to
those meetings and just giggle oh yeah
giggle my ass off but the only way i can
get out of going to meetings with him is
if i had a job
so one day i applied for a place called
crest kill liquors
just three white guys that didn't have a
clue
the owner was a good guy but he was just
the widest dude in america and he was a
sweetheart
they had one of those old registers
again one of those registers that
you had a hit of nine eight and a nine
and then plus then it would give you the
tax yeah and
you know if you got a bottle of scotch
that was 49.99
i'd put 9.99 and then give you change
like you gave me 320s and i would keep
pocket that 40. i would work from four
to eight
and i would walk out of there with like
500 bucks they couldn't figure it out
nobody could then the three guys are
there watching me
[ __ ] dog and i'm taking it running to
the city
cop and reef and coming back in the
house like nothing happened oh my god
i [ __ ] i worked at that place from
maybe the last week of january
to like the second week of march
and then one day i came in and they were
like listen
we figured out what you're doing
whenever you don't work
we make money whenever you work we get
zero profit we don't we couldn't figure
it out we finally figured out you're
[ __ ] fired
how'd they figure it out because that's
the time i figured out that that
there was a huge gap yeah every time i
was there they were always 400 hours
lighter than that
i didn't know that i worked and they
couldn't figure out like
it behooved them how i was doing it i
was doing it to the register you stupid
[ __ ] right in front of them i was doing
it
and they'd be looking at me and i
behooved them and then later on i paid
what i i do the math in my head i had
the math count how many 20s i was taking
and i got 180 coming to me i just take
180.
and then another guy will come in let me
get two bottles of this kind of whiskey
the 300 order i charge 30. so if it was
330
yeah i would do the math in my head if
it's 330 dollars i'd charge them 30
and i'd take 300 right off the [ __ ]
top
and they figured out now i'm on
suspension
this whole time from a barton and john
new york
okay i'm on suspension what is this i'm
collecting
like i'm a [ __ ] wild man i'm
collecting and i don't give a [ __ ]
okay like you're supposed to collect if
you're unemployed i'm collecting and i'm
working i'm stealing with two hands
like that was all part of the [ __ ]
deal like i'm collecting
and that's those are days when you went
down and they gave you 450 cash or
whatever the [ __ ] they gave you
they give you cash in those days you got
to go to a window it was right down the
corner from kentucky fried chicken
and yeah it was called gino's it's
kentucky fried chicken and burger king
or something put together
it was a chain in the 70s okay so gino's
was kentucky fried chicken and some
other work did gino's it was you know it
was gino marquette's
um restaurant something crazy defensive
end number 89 for the ball
what was it it was a kentucky fried
chicken it was like burgers and chicken
yeah
absolutely so uh i think more of the
burgers though but whatever
gino's was his i didn't know they went
up that they went up to jersey
well this chain wasn't just it was a
fast food chain
and so i was doing all this [ __ ]
and i'm still on suspension from new
york
and one day he says something to me he
goes listen uh
my wife knows you're getting high and
that wasn't the deal
you got about a week you know he didn't
say in a bad way
like he loved me to death i just needed
to go
so i picked up a little studio apartment
in tennefly new jersey
all right i quit my i got fired from
that [ __ ] job
and i don't know what i did i was just
banging around the city all day
i had a little money put away a couple
grand maybe a grand
and i would just you know just walk
around the city
go get a bag of dope maybe apply for a
job
you know i didn't really know what to
[ __ ] to do
so i went back to what i usually do
stealing so
i'm living in time to fly and i'm living
in the house it's what's the [ __ ] they
got today airbnb
yeah this is like an airbnb a woman
lived in the house
she lived downstairs her sons had moved
out
and she had three spare bedrooms
upstairs so she rented it to
two guys and a check you never saw the
chick
the other dude was a cuban dude so we
would talk from time to time me and the
cuban do whatever
and one day i'm leaving the son comes
home
the son comes in he's like oh you're
living with my mother i'm like yeah how
you doing my name is nick i don't know
what his name is
okay we start talking and right off the
bat the guy's like
i'm making the squad today you want to
come with me like th this is only [ __ ]
that happens to me
you've never seen this guy but he
thought i was cool because i lived in
his mother's house yeah right right
right and i remember like you weren't
allowed like the rule was you weren't
allowed to use the kitchen
or watch tv when she was you know that
was part of the thing
as soon as that [ __ ] left i was on the
phone
calling long distance watson's cable
i'm making sandwiches i had no
respect for nothing right like there was
nothing i had respectful like nothing
so me and her son like this is after i'm
there like three four weeks
it puts you like maybe march me and her
son
go out and he tells me about this car
he's gonna go look at it belongs to a
bookie
some [ __ ] and we bust into the [ __ ]
car and there's maybe 200 bucks
but there's jewelry we split the
yardstick
and we split the jewelry okay
i go my way he goes his way i got a guy
in the [ __ ] city that i go in there
no id
he melts it it's worth 80. he gives you
65 with no id what do you want to do
you want that's gold you want to take
the gold price right here
i turned the camera off what do you want
to do here give me 65 turn the camera is
it gold is that what it was
gold it was like a gold watch or
something well [ __ ]
takes it to a real pawn shop they do a
police report on it and three days later
i'm in my little house eating a bologna
sandwich
scratching my nuts on the ladies
watching tv
you're in his mom's house i'm on her
phone
sniffing her bras you know [ __ ] oh
and also right here and this is jose
here yeah i'm jose can you please come
on you're under arrest
for possession of stolen and he got
pinched
and he ratted me out ah so now that like
what'd you do with the jewelry i go what
jewelry
i knew my jewelry wasn't going to be
found i knew that jewelry was melted
gone that was on some greek guy's hand
already that was done
they made the ring and gave it to some
swami you know those rings those
immigrants in new york where with the
with the ruby they hypnotized and [ __ ]
so oh god so
i get thrown i get back to the apartment
and i okay i get arrested but let me
tell you what's more interesting about
this arrest
i did the thing with this kid
and i used to be a walker i always go
i'm walking like why would i take a bus
i said let me walk it's a beautiful day
so i was in tena fly and i think i don't
know where i walked
and i started walking that same
[ __ ] day as i'm walking i look over
and i see a kid
rake in the backyard and i know this kid
he's not i mean both he's from a town
called cliffside
and i'm from north bergen we met in
summer school my
freshman summer okay okay and i was i
stayed friends with him but very
distantly
i would now we were old i would bump
into him in clubs in the city
i see him raking there and i go george
and he turns around he goes what the
[ __ ] you doing up here like oh you know
me i'm casing stuff
and he starts laughing and researching
and he's like how you doing nothing how
you been
so he start talking one thing leads to
another
uh he's telling me he's a gardener and
he works with his mother part-time
so we get to talk and he writes down his
number
and he goes call me man i go [ __ ] i'll
call you
i'm looking for a friend thank god
so i go do something and
go get weed and when i come back home
that's when they knocked on the door of
the cops
so here's the funny thing whatever i
went to do whatever mile i walked
was to get something to eat and then
the store was closed or something that i
can't remember
my memory and i walked back and i was
still hungry and that's when they
arrested me
and they took me to
wherever i had they arrested me but i
had a warrant
from a different from my first pinch
yeah for possession of stolen property
okay so here i'm getting arrested for
possession
getting arrested only on this dude's
word that you
did this with me it was a uzi case okay
they can't they asked me what the
jewelry was i don't know what you're
talking about jewelry yeah they go if we
go into new york
all we're gonna do is make one call and
we'll find the paperwork i'm like
no you're not there's no paperwork yeah
i know these guys i
i spent the 15 years i already i i spent
the 15.
you're not going to find it so they took
me to the tana fly police department
and they realized they didn't have
enough evidence
so they said that's fine you got a
warrant anyway we're going to get you on
so we're going to take you to hackensack
now it's six o'clock it's seven o'clock
at night
i'm in [ __ ] identify or some [ __ ]
tend to fly whatever wherever they take
you
and now they gotta transfer me i gotta
wait for a [ __ ]
so the cop goes there's no more
transfers tonight
you might have to spend the night here
and i'm like ain't this a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and austin the cop goes i'm not doing
nothing
i'll transfer so i get in the car with
him
he has to take me to hackensack police
department to go in front of a judge
just like nine o'clock court
we're driving there and i'm talking to
the cop we're talking i tell them who i
am north bergen he's telling me he's
from fairview
we're talking we're talking finally i
got to ask you something
he goes what i go bro i haven't eaten
in like 10 [ __ ] hours he goes they
didn't feed your dinner all day oh no
he goes i don't know what to tell you i
go listen can you do me a favor
i go you got my paperwork today you know
who i am you got my fingerprints i got
handcuffs on
where am i going can we stop at chan's
dragon and this is my favorite chinese
restaurant you don't even ask
for fast we're gonna drive right through
it
the cop looks and he goes he goes he
goes you got a chance
that place is [ __ ] filthy he goes i
had to do a steak out there one night
there was supposedly gonna be there was
a guy who was robbing safes so we pinned
it down to where he was whatever he was
going to go
so we all did a steak out there one
night when they turned out the lights
we thought there were people in there we
turned the lights on there were rats
oh my god that's how big they were
because i'm not going in there
i go i don't give a [ __ ] if they got
rats you gotta go over there and get me
some pork fried rice
and they grow and the guy actually
stopped
we walked in there with my comes on yes
i did
i had him behind my back he switched it
to my front
i ordered he let me eat it in the back
of the car
and then throw it away and like [ __ ] it
then he put the handcuffs in on my back
and we went
and i owed him a solid like i had like a
get out of jail card in my wallet
i knew a lot of cops i was dropping
names it's just the guy's like okay
you're legit
so we get to the [ __ ] thing that was
com completely crazy you know none of
you i've never i mean night court was a
great show back in the day but that was
a real thing that's a real thing
i don't know it used to be until like
two in new york really 2 a.m
2 a.m at 1 00 a.m
[ __ ] tremendously so you're going up
in front are you actually in a court
room or are you doing like all the
sellers first okay they take me into a
cell first
and then they go diaz upstairs and when
i go upstairs i'm sitting there
handcuffed
and they go hold on one second you're
next but they got to bring this guy
because they got to take them to the
hospital
i'll never ever forget that they
probably they propped this [ __ ]
and like they they propped him in he
walked in like jesus
like there was a trail of blood behind
his leg you think i'm [ __ ] kidding
they propped him up and he's like guilty
murder whatever the [ __ ]
you know 30 days whatever i don't know
what he got i don't know what he did i
know that there was a line of blood
following him like they had thrown a
tremendous beat on him they shot him
but he was answering you all right after
the [ __ ] judge you're [ __ ]
the guy who's like yeah
they like hit him right there again with
the sticks and i'm like damn
so i got nobody to call
they go uh mr diaz because i made
bail but what i didn't do was complete
the program or some [ __ ] and that's why
you got the warrant that's why i had the
warrant
i had a close in the head's amount of
fuel listen just go to the two days
of this thing uh you're gonna go here
we're gonna go
there's no bail you're amanda it's
[ __ ] 11 o'clock
where am i gonna go i just got thrown
out of my house
you know the cop the cop said the lady
was going to put the bag out with my
stuff
oh my god damn it i got to go all the
way to town to fly
get my bag of clothes my bag of clothes
right
not even so i wanted my pocket
and i found george's number and i go
george
he picks up the first ring 201 943-2629
wow 1985 baby that's the memory on uncle
joey
ask me what i have for lunch you'll
throw me off it's like jeopardy
it's like being the dumbest guy in
jeopardy but ask me what somebody's
number was in high school i still
remember it so
i thought that number's about to get
called like a [ __ ]
they [ __ ] um he answered
and i go george i need a big favor you
gotta take me telephone to pick up my
clothes and drive me off on a hotel
on route 4. i was in and out of those
hotels i knew them 44 a night
i was a lifeguard at one of those
[ __ ] next to you yeah
there's no lifeguards at these hotels
you go out there you just drown you
shoot heroin
they put you into the pool nobody knows
nothing you know what i'm saying
people go outside actually look at you
for a second they'll call that kids come
here
look what happens to heroin people see
take a picture
you like it being from london so
george takes me to get my clothes
and i go all right let's just go to roof
when he goes nah now you're gonna come
and stay with me
because i talked to my mother you could
stay with me in my room you could sleep
on the floor
um are you [ __ ] serious so he took me
home
he introduced you to his mom his grandma
only this could happen to me and i moved
him with him like in mid-march
and he came on my podcast he did about a
month ago he did a zoom
and he goes i guess i knew you were the
first
deal the first two to two weeks he goes
the first two weeks
you broke into my roommate's house you
stole his [ __ ] speakers
and i stole his unemployment check and i
cashed it
that's like a cash anything i had a guy
in the bank he didn't give a [ __ ] his
introduction whatever you want to do
like whatever you need what kind of
check you got
from the plumber's union who's it
belonging to ivan volsky give it to me
he'll sign ivan and we were cash to
check i mean there was the trout
the guy was alone she worked for a loan
shark so if you borrowed from the loan
shark
he would cut you a check to the bank and
you would go see my friend
so i move him with george
and they uh spoke spanish they're from
panama
and we stalked and at night i'd stay in
with his grandma i was clean
i wasn't doing any coke i was smoking
aretha
but i wasn't drinking nothing like that
i didn't have a girlfriend
i didn't get laid from life that august
like i had been what i don't want i i
turned so much into coke
that really wasn't even into women
anymore like i wasn't into men either
i was
i was 20 [ __ ] one i was 22
it was 1985. i was worth zero
i was clean though and and this is a
connection coming
back from your past childhood with a guy
from summer
school or whatever 79. right before
there's something before my mother
because you were up there casing that
place and he's just breaking a year
whatever
yeah and i stay with him i get a job
right off the bat for a
bricklayer and i'm laying brick with the
guy
italians good guys i did that for about
seven weeks and then the bar called me
back
oh it's just a friend of mine called a
friend of mine
and said they want to meet with you this
is a very like official bar [ __ ] here it
was a sheridan
senate oh okay 52nd and 7th okay
and i was under investigation for theft
you know there was just cell room
charges room
i mean there was 8 000 ways to rob that
hotel yeah and all those guys did it
everybody who worked at the hotel
was robbing people i mean it was
horrific what and it just
i didn't invent it i don't want anybody
to think i invented it
i walked into this and these guys like
you want to make money
do this i worked at a hotel in the front
door
send it to you then you would deny it
we would out of the room remember tell
the people to clean it real quick
if they paid cash say ah they don't like
the side they want this side to view and
boom they will clean it real quick and
we would keep that 500 thing in the
world people hotel employees are defeat
[ __ ]
that's why i don't put my safe inside
nothing in that safe man your business
take it with you because there's people
like me so
i'm moving with him wait i gotta say
something dude this is the truth
dude because of you that's sitting down
and talking to you when you're like i'll
break into your
[ __ ] sliding glass door or whatever
my daughter and i will go down to the
pool and i mean down our stairs to the
pool and i
shut and locked my goddamn
she's like it's hot in here when we come
back well i don't give a [ __ ] it's all
still here though and
i every time i think joey has to climb
right on this balcony and get up in here
and i wanted something i was gonna take
it
so i hear you i shut i do it every time
when i think of you we are we are
50 feet away so i went into the city
and they told me that they weren't gonna
hire me back blah blah blah blah blah
blah
they gave me some type of severance
they said not to call there for a
reference
that they would give a bad reference
and i can't imagine you had any real
good they gave me like i don't know i
don't even know what they gave me like
800
something how long did you crazy i
worked there legitimately yeah
like bullshitly a year and a half
but legitimately maybe
eight months with no problems okay
stealing
yeah but no problem right not you know
then i would just not call in not show
up
you know i was just being 22 being a kid
i was a [ __ ] dumb
i was a 21 year old i thought i wanted a
bartender and this whole
thing but i'm living with george before
i moved in with george
i was living in a hotel and one night i
was really broke
and i went across the street there's a
string of gas stations
right so i'm living with before i moved
in with george
i think it was before i got the
apartment
with that lady when i was looking for
the apartment i stayed in fort lee for a
while because it's closer to the city
fort lee fort lee new jersey is right
across from manhattan on the bridge
they have all these hotels it's where a
comedy club called bananas is
if they ever ask you to play bananas
it's in it's right there on route 4
next to the bada bing that's why people
go to bananas because they go to the
bada-bing
so i don't think it's still open it
doesn't matter but
one night i was staying at that hotel
and i was hungry
one afternoon and i crossed the street
to the gas station because that's how
much money i had
and i saw for help beside and i asked
the guy what what are you looking for
and he goes
i need to marry a pumpkin okay
where can i start he goes tonight he
goes what's your name i'm like
ryan sickler he's like a lion cichlid
okay i see you at four o'clock so i come
back and i
realize i'm by myself so he trains me
for the first hour
in jersey and oregon they pump gas yep
still right
isn't it illegal to pump your own gas in
jersey that's crazy to me you gotta pump
gas
and oregon still too yeah i don't know
but it is still jersey
2020. i think in oregon they're just
lighting people on fire
you're right they got a bigger
so i went across the street and i'm
pumping all this gas
and he told me it was it's like
nighttime so drop
every time you got 500 in your pocket
put an envelope
but what time sign this paperwork and
put a drop in there
i don't i didn't see the reason to you
know so every
hour like he told me i'd take like a
dollar bill and drop
it a dollar bill because for some reason
it was like computerized he goes i'll
find that in my house if you don't drop
so about [ __ ] two o'clock i realized
i got about 1200
plus what's ever in the register plus
the food
plus he's got a box of change under the
[ __ ] register
so i took everything i took
everything at three o'clock hershey bars
the whole [ __ ] thing
and i just walked across route four
jumped over the [ __ ] banister
in the side of it cars were whizzing by
me doing 90
and i went home the next morning i look
up i look out my hotel window
cops are there the whole thing people
have been pumping gas for free for four
hours
because i just left i just left i just
left i just left right i forgot
i said [ __ ] that [ __ ]
he was pissed he came back his name is
so i figured this out but here's the
problem you got
you got a road gas station going that
way and you got the royal gas stations
going this way for me
that's a [ __ ] hit yeah so i wait like
three days sure enough i go to the gas
station
two doors down from that guy
that [ __ ] needs help twelve to eight
but here's the story the
real story was my buddy worked at house
yes i used to get the chest
i still talk to this guy he's still one
of my best friends in the world
so i told him to give me a list of
anybody who ever got fired for stealing
and he sent me a list of names so i
would apply under those names
yeah so now i was smart the second time
the second time i went in there
what's your name tony ramirez where have
you pumped gas yes
where we hawking yet when can you start
what do you got
12 to 8 i'm in i'd get there at 12 and
again
once i get a thousand that's it that's
it i put a dollar in the envelope
i just walk off even if i was working i
wanted to
you know even like you always working
with some guy and a jacket on
i'd say this i'm going to go to the
bathroom
i did this every two gas stations then i
went across the street
and worked myself back 1200 1800
god it was always something and that's
that old-school gas [ __ ] where you
pulled the lever out of the way oh yeah
there was none of that
and then that umpire and then you also
used to hung gang
hang gas hand gas means
brian's sick was a broke [ __ ] he comes
in and gets four hours worth of gas
when lee comes in for gas guess who's
swallowing that four
lee is that four is going right into
lee's i'm gonna put that thing in
without popping the thing back
i'm remember because you had to pop it
all right yeah you did but if you didn't
pop it all the way back and just put it
in there the car would move up
and then that make believe it's already
on four by the time i'm putting it in
right you're like
i'm making the first four dollars this
was hysterical
i mean like yeah hanging pumps that's
what it was that's what i meant
so i would hang pumps not only would i
hang pumps i wasn't even gonna pay for i
wasn't even gonna pay the gas man anyway
so i did that all around that gas
station
all the way back and then i took my then
i took my show on the road
and i took it down to south jersey and
i started hitting them all over south
jersey every day i take a bus
and it was hilarious i would take a bus
to a new area get out
see a gas station walk the three of them
and get hired by one
i'd go somewhere eat and stand there
like an [ __ ] for six
hours until i had to go back and forth
to train because they take
can you start today at four [ __ ] yeah
i'll start today at four
and i get back there at four o'clock i'd
pump gas till 10.
i'd be working with some guy can i go to
the bathroom yes but heavy up
we're not running a chatter here all
right yeah good and i just go
sometimes i call george i would call
george lego george meet me there
and 10 after 9. why 10 afternoon just
beat her at 10 after 9.
and george would be that thing and he
was just picking me up coming off the
bus
i get in the cargo hit it why
just hit it cause i just robbed the guy
what are you talking about you rob the
guy
i give him two bills he's 200 don't
worry about nothing so tell me what
happened so one time
i did this all over new jersey oh my god
this was hysterical
this is [ __ ] hysterical so now
i'm not going to tell you the name of
the place this is a huge gas station
like to pull this one off it was like
ocean's 11. you know what i'm saying
right
because they had like 18 gas guys
this place is huge like a truck stop
like a truck yeah
like let's just you know yeah sure
enough
[ __ ] boom the [ __ ]
they need me from four to twelve and
it's non-stop
it's about to rain so i'm going from one
car to the other
everybody twenties twenties tens
fifteens
the [ __ ] thing is getting thicker
yeah stacked my hands are filthy from
all the dollars
i'm handling they had to have four guys
on one island
you know just pumping doubles you're
doing big rigs and [ __ ] like that i'm
doing everything i'm doing everything
i'm pumping get no i
i wasn't doing diesel i was just doing
cars
so i'm doing cars and also in the
[ __ ]
sky is starting to turn gray i'm doing
cars i'm doing cars
the sky is starting to turn ground like
[ __ ]
and i called george and i asked the guy
to go hold on can i go make a call
and i called george at his mom's shop
and he goes i can't get to you
we got a special order man i'm sorry i
don't know what to take oh [ __ ]
so i got like 2 000 in my pocket i'm
working and it's
about to rain but it was also
park and drive mm-hmm is that what they
call them park and ride where
people are you meet and get in one car
yeah
park and ride we used to have those all
over america there's buses that go into
new york from there
so sure enough parking i'm looking at
these buses and they're lining up
and you get on any of them because
they're all going to new york and i see
all these people
so i got like two 2g 2100 i go up to a
little [ __ ]
indian dude like listen i gotta go take
a [ __ ] i got diarrhea huh
heady up with a busy mom can't you see
this i go yeah
and i dodged to the bathroom but i just
come out the side door
there's a ton of people and i just mix
into the new york line
and i get on the bus and i'm watching
this [ __ ] guy
and this guy is pumping gas when he's
looking at the door to see if he sees me
he's pumping gas he's looking at the
door and after about five minutes i'm
getting that cheat my bus is i'm waiting
for the bus to fill
okay you're okay the guy's not gonna get
off until the bus fills up my god damn i
got on the wrong bus
i'm on the second bus and there's still
a bus in front of me
and now i see the guy go you know like
hold on one second
and he goes in there looking for me now
i see the guy
run out and like he's like looking
around for me
and he runs back to his little [ __ ]
friends he's like you know he
and i'm watching all this go down and
all of a sudden he runs into the office
and he gets on a [ __ ] phone
and they're [ __ ] calling somebody and
then they're all looking around and
another guy goes in there looking for me
and i'm telling the bus driver let's go
let's go
it's gonna [ __ ] rain and i mean the
[ __ ] scout
the skies are [ __ ] turning gray and
[ __ ] and they're looking around and
finally when my bus takes off as my bus
takes off they're all looking around
like where the hell does this guy go
one of them figured out he's on one of
those buses so i'm like
oh no so as i'm pulling out of there i
see
cops pulling in oh [ __ ] i'm dead
so bus pulls out i figure they're going
to arrest us when we get in the poll
authority
i get the port authority there's not a
cop inside
i walked out to broadway they didn't
stop you when you were leaving
nothing oh no [ __ ] nothing we didn't
stop them
we got on route 3 right to new york
i went i picked up george we took a
shower we got dressed and we went to
this club in the city
with another friend of mine devo and we
went to the club and the eurythmics were
there hanging out just hanging out
like you couldn't even talk to them i
thought i was a [ __ ] big shot and
[ __ ]
but i stayed with and at that time i was
just doing creepy [ __ ]
how much would you say average you
probably hit in the gas stations at 1500
to 2 grand a pop
a pop yet and about what does this
yeah like wow what's the biggest maybe
like it was like 2400 and i had like 15
of them but i had a thousand scams going
i just
didn't want to stick to one scam i
wanted to throw enough spaghetti i would
do something for two weeks
then lay off it because i know now they
were hot for it
like i'd put a suit on at that time i
was good friends with these dudes that
were running a credit card day
these were legit dudes they also had
counterfeit money
you could buy money by the pound from
them you could buy money
this was crazy i had been involved with
these dudes as a
like i didn't really know them and i met
them later on in the game through drugs
but then later that's real [ __ ] right 84
is when i found out what these guys were
about
and when ryan sickler orders a credit
card they had it so wired that the guy
who makes
credit cards would make two credit cards
one for you and your name and one for
them in your name
i mean it was crazy it was this corrupt
these guys had tapped into so much
corruption
they were into travelers checks they
went to credit cards
anything for these past 500
got you a birth certificate driver's
license
social security card and an insurance
card
for your car a fake insurance card
that would work like they would call get
a [ __ ] name on it i mean it's crazy
it was all done like brooklyn the baker
i forgot what the guy's name was but i
just got involved with these guys that
were high level
so i started buying credit cards from
them and i started buying suits
and what i would do is go into big time
office buildings and just look for
people to make a mistake you have no
idea how many times i have opened up a
door
and seen the bank deposit for the day
sitting on your table
and i just put under my jacket walk out
of the building
yeah take the cash and throw away the
checks and everything
okay so during this time you're 25 you
said
no baby i'm 22. okay 22. are you
looking to outside of that bartending
gig are you looking to
really work anywhere or are you just
hustling
i'm looking to get a paid day but do you
know where you want to go
i'm going i'm back to colorado i'm going
to go back i'm going to
this time i'm doing it right i'm going
to go to uh
colorado springs and work myself up to
aspen by november
that was the plan okay and all of a
sudden
i'm doing all this illegal [ __ ] and it's
the beginning of june
and i got a call from a friend of mine
and he says they're looking for you
did you do some phony insurance scam and
i go yeah cause the lawyer's got a check
for you
okay come on what and they're like they
got a check for you call the lawyer
so one of the yellow pages got the
lawyer's name i called him up
i go this is jose diaz do you have the
heels yeah i got
i got a check for you yeah uh come to my
office and get it on friday at 1.
it was probably june
29th it was a friday
and i went to israel he told me to be at
his office like two i was there for ten
to two
i went in i did the paperwork when i
looked at the check and said eighteen
grand
damn and that's for what
some phony insurance [ __ ] some guy got
me involved in
i took the check to my friend's dad he
cashed it i owed him a little bit of
money
for gambling and [ __ ] probably he cashed
it
i told him to hold on till 10 for the
weekend i still wasn't doing coke
i was pretty good so what i did was
i went and bought a card with a huge
limit
and i took my friend lubes and this girl
who had taken care of me
and george couldn't go
this girl worked for
ann taylor whatever that company was
i think that's right i mean it sounds
familiar division yeah
she was a general manager of the shoe
division so she had access to credit
cards and stuff
so whenever i went to that mall i would
give her a credit card and that's the
old school
yeah these credit cards yeah she would
call in and see how much limit i would
have
okay because she would do it for women
all the time women go i want to buy
those 800
shoes but i don't know what i got left
in the car so she would call
and they'd tell her you know 20 grand so
i took her and
my friend lubes and i took him [ __ ]
shopping in that mall
i go whatever the [ __ ] you want
whatever you want on a saturday and
we've got i got the white miami vice
suit
i had everything i just bought a whole
new [ __ ] wardrobe
gold chains
i took my friends out to dinner
like four of us i took them out to a
good [ __ ] place called piccalissimo
they had a dish called lobster for a
diablo
and i and i and i knew people were
looking for me
i knew i was on the hit list i knew that
anybody could find me at any time my
godfather the dudes i beat
west new york oh i had them everywhere
so i took them to eat off the beaten
path
and then that night i had already made
my mind i was taking the one o'clock
flight
from newark jet uh jetblue was called
people's express
now here i got 18 grand and jet
people's express you paid for it on the
plane with a credit card
you had to go stand online and then that
they picked you
and you sounded scary oh my god they had
a flight every two hours
they only flew they only flew from yeah
they only flew from newark to cottonwood
newark la
and newark to london darren what's that
bust that everyone used to roll like uh
new york to
boston or whatever the chinese bus it
always break down on the side of road
people tell me about all the time
i know what you know what's all about
that's what it sounds like the airline
version of that
yeah people's expressions people's
express people they went to l.a they
came here they came
here they went to l.a because i took
them one time i was taking them so much
on stolen credit cards
like i would just get out there with
stolen so you would get on and then you
sit down and then they run you
it was 49 bucks one way bye
man that's if you just want a chair oh
you want cushions
that's another 10. oh you want a salad
that's another thing you want to be at
22.
so i get on there and buy everybody
drinks give them all drinks give the
whole world drinks
give everybody drinks give them on
drinks on me because i've been giving
them joe schwing's [ __ ] crazy
mr jennings yeah you're welcome take
so and what happened was i was beating
them for so long
and one time i was out here the time i
got to the beef with my uncle
i got into beef and i got on one of
those and i was going to beat them
you know i was going to get on the plane
when they came to me they go where's
your credit card i go
i left it on my luggage and like okay
we'll see you afterwards
i thought they were going to forget i'm
like this is how crazy i am i'm like
they're gonna forget
[ __ ] you they had two ramp agents down
there
and they went with me to my luggage we
took it to a secure place
i looked around i said i didn't have and
they go okay you have an option
this is theft we call the cops
or you call somebody to pay it right now
and come get you
another call friend of mine who was
pissed at me
and he's like you're [ __ ] crazy i
gotta pay 69
now jesus [ __ ] christ i'll be right
down there
he had to come to new york oh he had to
come down oh
it was horrible it was [ __ ] horrible
they didn't do it over there
yeah like there was 1 800 western union
this summer
so now i i [ __ ] i'm leaving sunday
morning
and it's saturday night and i'm with my
buddies and i'm having a good time and
i'm not doing blow i got a couple drinks
i mean i go to this bar called the spot
in union city
my friend's uncle worked there and he
would give you cuban crackers
he was irish what's that but he would
give you cuban crackers with mortadella
cheese on it oh
mortadella ham and little cheese and and
give you tidbits
so i'm very eating and i'm having a good
time with my friends there's a couple
chicks i'm looking at
i'm not snorting and all of a sudden one
of the hottest friends i have
comes walking in the door her name is
regina god bless us
all she's dead now i hadn't seen in
about eight months
and she sees me she lights up she gives
me a [ __ ] hug
and she goes i gotta talk to you about
something
and there's a cop in the bar and he's my
cousin
his name is julio i grew up with him
we're not blood cousins but i've known
him since i
grew up with his brother me and his
brother were huge [ __ ] friends we
used to run numbers together we were
kids all three of us
even him as a cop when he was a kid when
he was 12 we all read numbers for the
same bookie on sundays
we were family i'm watching him he's
just staring at me i'm like
[ __ ] something's not right and this girl
pulls me aside and she goes listen
i just want you to know that those
people
they know it was you i'm trying to play
it off but it's like you coming up to me
going
they know and i'm like come on you know
me but at night she's like knock it off
they got a description they saw you
going in
you went down in a blue car they watched
the whole thing go down they're looking
for you
they have not called the cops they are
physically looking for you
i'm like [ __ ] she just took the energy
out of me
and i went up to the ball and i paid the
table let me go talk to my cousin give
him a hug
and i go up to him and i go holy i'll
see you next time he goes i think you
should leave
and i go what are you talking about he
goes i think you should leave there's a
lot of people that you pissed off you
should really [ __ ] leave
i was like okay when i got in the car
and i was like that's
it this ain't just a [ __ ]
i gotta go so i went back to george's
that night
went to bed like 12 my flight was like i
won
george couldn't take me to the airport
he had to do something that day
so i had to take a bus to jersey city
and my friend was going to take me to
the airport
wake up the next day i put some money in
george's grandmother
for bingo when i lived there i would
take care of her bingo bill that was one
of my responsibilities
give her a 20 for bingo i gave her like
100.
for like a couple nights of bingo i gave
the mother rent
the mother would charge me like 50 bucks
a week i gave the mother like 100 bucks
and i get a
i think i take a cab to white castle on
88th street
because that's where the bus came for
jersey city
i got my military bag i got my shorts on
and i'm free man i'm ready to go to
[ __ ] colorado
holy [ __ ] this has been 18
months of pure [ __ ] hell this has
been i'm going
and all of a sudden my bus pulls up
number one nun guesses that nun guess is
what they call that bowling alley that's
what they call that that's the number
one bus
that takes you from north bergen to
jersey city but the bus driver gets out
he doesn't take a piss
he goes into white castle take a piss
i'm sitting out there with my bag and i
hear a motorcycle
run run run run i don't think nothing of
it
just a [ __ ] motorcycle got nothing to
do with me
i look over at the white cast when i
keep him in the motorcycle
and the motorcycle goes he goes around
the [ __ ]
bus and he makes a u-turn around the bus
and rides up on the sidewalk and comes
right towards me
what and he's running like what the [ __ ]
dirt bike
yeah and then i had a there was a
there was a side pocket i had a little
32 is that what they called a little 32
and i just my bag was
it would look like a punching bag it was
looking like 38
yeah it was 38 special that little no
another little one yeah
it wasn't a 22. i think it was a who the
[ __ ] no
38 special i think it was a tiny one
that a friend that i stole and that's
the one i pulled on my uncle in
california
that's the one i still had that gun i'd
never fired it i'd never oiled it it was
in that [ __ ] thing
guess what i was going to colorado with
it i was just going to take it out and
put it in my luggage
okay so here
and the bike is coming towards me i
reach
and it's like a flap and i just happen
to
grab the gun the guy doesn't know i have
the gun but i'm let i'm righty
it's in my left hand i ain't gonna do me
no [ __ ] good
and he pulls up where you are and he
flips this thing and it's my godfather
who's been hunting me down
and he goes he goes hey remember when he
chased me in the bed
yeah all right i remember a motorcycle
okay he's
on a 50-something motorcycle i'm like
really i'm one of those chinese ones
what they call them rice zippers
whatever your [ __ ]
[ __ ] house it's rock paper scissors
rock what the [ __ ] they call it
and he comes up on one of those and in
spanish he goes
you never came by and gave me that money
did you
and i go gabby sorry he goes
the next time i see you because i'm
gonna put a bullet in you
damn he closed this thing and he took
off
i'm like [ __ ] i don't even know if i
should get on this bus
i said [ __ ] let me get on the bus i got
on the bus took me down to jersey city
my friend took me to the airport i got
online for people's express
i got on the plane with a fugazi credit
card
i get on this plane i'm headed to
colorado springs
colorado springs is where the air force
academy is
and it was the number one growing city
at the time
in 1985 was booming
so i forget like i said i'd go down
there make some money i got 18 grand to
play with
i had about 17 grand to play with
and i'll [ __ ] go to colorado i'll go
to aspen in november my buddy's up there
he's house sitting i'll get a job up
there i could stay in the garage for a
few days you don't know that yet
but that's the ride i'm gonna take on
the plane
it's a party i'm drinking
i'm just [ __ ] smoking weed it was
like a party on this place
that's that people so this is this is
this is crazy
i start talking to this african-american
dude
real good guy we just started talking
the whole way and he's like and this is
exactly what he told me because man how
old is you
i know i'm 23 because you ain't going no
colorado springs with them [ __ ]
soldiers
he goes you're going to bowl to get some
[ __ ] now i'm
i haven't gotten a piece of ass from
august of 84.
it is now july of 85. i'm
22 years old yeah i have nothing that's
like
10 years i have not even touched a woman
and it's coming up in a year well guess
what
on the [ __ ] plane i started talking
to the stories
she's in jersey we should start talking
now people's express was a [ __ ] party
you're in the middle aisle you're
talking to four people come here
waitress come here give him a drink
give him a drink give that table over
there a drink it was like you were in
good fellas
yeah it was a [ __ ] party like you fly
today it's
horrible it's a horrible experience
june of 85. you're giving orders you're
buying people drinking more
drinks give them all a double take a tip
and do you you have to do it the [ __ ]
store this is
drinking with you so i got this freak
drinking on the plane
we go downstairs we get our luggage do
you know what the store just says
she goes what hotel are you staying at
tonight i have no idea i don't even know
where i'm going because the plan was to
land and then i think we landed like a
10.
i was just going to take a hotel and
take a bus to boulder the next day
and look for an apartment and keep my
clothes at the hotel in denver rent this
like a week and go to boulder
because he told me to go to boulder he
talked bro i hated boulder
i [ __ ] hated bold i hate i went there
when i lived in aspen
it was just a little bit too hippie-ish
for me i wasn't ready for it it was like
the village i wasn't ready bro i get off
the [ __ ] plane
and this little cute store this is like
what hotel are you standing i don't know
where you guys staying and she goes
we're all supposed to stay
over there and go looks like i'm staying
over there she goes okay
so we took they went on the shuttle i
went in the shuttle with them
all the pilots were on there and they're
like in street clubs
and we went back to this hotel and she
goes i'm in room 218
i don't know what room i was in we went
to our rooms we all went down the front
bar
we were drinking and then later on she
came up to my room
and threw me a little 11 just like that
people's experience just like that
i get up the next morning just as
planned she leaves
i take a shower i i don't i didn't think
i drank coffee
i got the bus went to boulder
i started walking around boulder i saw a
free paper
and i'm walking down the street i bump
into this
[ __ ] girl that's a 10. nice big hits
and she's like are you looking for an
apartment i go yeah
she was me too we could do it together
come on i like that
just like that i'm like oh my god i
haven't talked to a girl in a year
there's my i'm here two days already i'm
already talking
about the back days so we both put she
went
and looked at her apartment i walked her
and then
i she walked me and i got my i put my
deposit
in from my apartment mine was 1012
14th street and she was like three doors
down
and she was moving in with her college
roommate
so we we spoke we wished each other luck
i don't think we went and got in there
was no coffee then
and i went back to denver got like a
steak went back to the hotel room
the lady called the hotel i got the
apartment i took my clothes i went to
boulder the next day
and i moved in two days later i'm going
to the gym
i see the chick with the big tits we
start talking she invites me over for
dinner
this is the craziest song of my life
and i the third night we start swap and
spit
but she's got a crazy roommate she's got
a higher girl
a girl that just won't quit always [ __ ]
blocking
and just as good looking as this one oh
yeah she would [ __ ] block like come out
topless with a thong on like
oh i didn't know you were here
so me and this girl this is going on i'm
lifting weights i joined the gym
it was downstairs there was a store
called roses
i would get the the rotisserie chicken
and that's all i lived on
rotisserie chicken that then i had a
japanese roommate he didn't speak
english
too good he's like i i broke i go you're
broke
don't worry about it let's go down to
alfalfa you got a new job your name is
kato
and you're going to be my international
chef so i called him cato
and that made him myself
he had a uh dude for a roommate that
played the guitar
he was in the finals oh you had to hear
this
three retards okay and i had a mexican
dude
that just came from mexico and he was
really like uh
like you know t senor you know he was
perfectly cast out of a [ __ ] movie
speedy gonzales so i'm only going there
at night basically to take showers
so i start sleeping with the big teddy
girl
so i'm pretty much hanging out with her
all the time i'm lifting weights
and even though i opened up a bank
account i put the 10 g's in the bank
and i kept the other eight just to run
with you know i
pop cato off at 20 every day
go down to alfalfa get some beef get
some scallions
get some nice jasmine rice you know
jasmine i love josh
i know jasmine though that was his name
so now so they would have parties at
night those three morons
would like say hey where you going we're
going to have an egg guitar finals so
i'm like what are you kidding me
i'm going next door to get my dick
sucked yeah i mean what's the matter
with you guys
and i would come back and they'd all be
staring at me like they didn't like me
like you're not part of this house
you're no good and then the girl
tells me about i go i don't know where
they got me reefer out here
and she goes well the people next door
for me seemed to smoke pot
so one day i just knocked next door i
don't mind
i smelled some reef like come on in
i saw reefer she was like 50 he was like
20.
she was maybe 48 the ugliest woman you
ever seen
she could stop bird [ __ ] mid-air if
she looks up
the break shouldn't stop she wore a
little yoko oh no glasses
she was almost as ugly as yoko oh no i'm
not good sir
but this woman was bird dog ugly and her
boyfriend was like 20 years younger
that was her boyfriend not her son no he
was a trust fund baby with a ponytail
with little glasses
used to roll his own cigarettes nerdy
couldn't hurt a fly
they were the sweetest dirtiest couple
you ever met and she just sat there all
day drinking and he would run errands
for her
and she would sell me weed so i'm
getting weed from them
i'm hooking up with this chick i'm doing
all this stuff
right and um but i'm bored
so i call my buddies and i go listen
this is my ad just 10 12.
send out some credit cards i'm bored
so they start sending me out credit
cards there's a little mall in boulder
but i mean i'm bored after 10 days right
10 days july 10th i'm already bored they
send me credit cards
i start using credit cards all around
the mall
chains uh you should have seen my room
you ever seen coming to america
yeah when he redid his room yeah yeah
i looked at four retards i had a tv
vcr i had every movie
where are you getting all this stuff
from i'm like i make money you [ __ ]
kato
make breakfast i cater on breakfast
lunch and dinner
so hysterical
bruce lee's chinese too that's so oh
yeah
and he didn't speak no english and his
parents cut him off
because they want him to be a doctor he
wanted to be an astronaut
so they cut him off so now i got the kid
[ __ ] i'm duking them 20s every time i
see him
i'm duke i got to duke him 20's to get
rid of him too because i'd bring a girl
over right away he wants to come over
and translate
with sign language he thought he was
garcetti's fat little [ __ ] sign
language chick
so i would have to give him a douglas
and you got to go where go where go cook
what do i pay you for i don't pay you to
stand there cook
so come on sunday the gym
where i'm going to has this big annual
barbecue
it's still july i'm already i haven't
even been there a month
i'm sleeping with this girl she's got a
crazy roommate i'm coughing weed and i'm
already using the credit card
all right
we go to this barbecue i'm having a good
time with this girl i'm dating but we
bring a roommate
the hot one with that we come out with
the thong and the [ __ ] you could hear
the dildos in there and [ __ ]
three weeks of this [ __ ] i'm looking at
this girl i'm like she's a piece of ass
so we're at this barbecue so help me god
and i'm sitting there and the girl i'm
with
it's actually flirting with another dude
right in front of me
now i'm not a boyfriend but at least
don't flirt in front of me take his
number cop it for the side
and when i'm not around you can suck his
dick that's got nothing to do with me
i'm not that type of guy
so she's talking to things so the
roommate's got three drinks in her
and she's talking wild [ __ ] then the
pussy's so good i'm missing out on it
that i'm [ __ ] the wrong chick you
want to stab him
she goes i go i'll [ __ ] you right over
there by that wall
you think i'm kidding you we went over
that wall
everybody could see us it was only like
a three foot brick wall
it was maybe a three foot brick wall
everybody could see us we jumped over
the wall she took her panties off and i
did a doggy style they're playing like
tennis
in the middle they're cooking hamburgers
and i'm doggiest
girl and all you can see is like from my
rib
cage up and i'm working this ass right
this is hysterical now i gotta get in
the car with both of them
and the one girl is yelling [ __ ] you you
stole my boyfriend he wasn't my
boyfriend
[ __ ] you they get into a it was horrible
so now i lose them both
both of them are pissed at me i lost my
piece of ass
the whole thing goes down the drain i'm
sitting in my room when then i go you
know what this is [ __ ] i i could
have
done this dumb [ __ ] in jersey i gotta
get my life together
let me go get a job so i start putting
applications
in it's a college town it doesn't pick
up till september
i go everywhere everywhere but guess
what my mistake was
without even thinking i go back to this
mall
and i go in the mall and i start passing
on applications
and one place where i heard was great to
work with footlocker
so i go to footlock give him an
application the guys from new york right
away we start talking he goes
i only got part-time you can start
tomorrow boom
i'll start tomorrow i had to be the end
of july
i start first day i'm selling sneakers
you know after three or four days
i know how to run the joint so i'll
never forget this
and i got to say this story i'm very
ashamed of the story
this is what started it all
what do you mean by it this is what
started the whole rotation of downward
for me so okay
i'm doing great at this [ __ ] place
i'm making strides we're going out for
beers afterward
like i was part of the crew i'm there
about two weeks
i don't know what time i had to go to
work you had to you had the ref jersey
and all that yeah the whole thing with
black pants
we were just about to do paperwork
no let's not speed it up i'm doing great
there
everything's going great and one day i
have to go on in the afternoon
and my room is dirty where the [ __ ] is
the vacuum
i go on cato where's the vacuum i don't
know i don't know what i'm thinking
okay the [ __ ] white dude he don't
know because there's supposed to be a
vacuum for the building
so as i go out of my apartment
you're not gonna believe this story as i
go out of my apartment
to look for the vacuum there's a girl in
my hallway
and we both look at each other and we go
is that you
two years earlier i was in tempe
arizona and i met a girl at the airport
talking we were both delayed and she
goes i love your accent
no [ __ ] where are you from she goes
boulder
i go i'm from new jersey she goes my
sister lives in jersey her husband has
an accident like yours
we started talking she goes where you
head i go back to jersey
she goes you know what i'm gonna go to
jersey soon why don't you exchange
numbers and i'll call you
she called i would give her like my
friend's number i didn't have a phone
one of my friend called looks for me he
goes hey some girl kathy called you
and she's staying at such and such on
wednesday
so i gotta hold her at the hotel and i
went over and met her
i just met her in arizona so
we basically went to like joe's pizza in
one of those pizza places in new york
and walked around for two hours got me
my witness i didn't even try to do
anything
i was such i was in such a slump then
a [ __ ] didn't even go for it because i
knew the answer was going to be no
so i walked it back to the hotel like a
gentleman i go i'll see you some other
time
and she gave me a colorado number
but in all my [ __ ] drugs this is
march of 84 when i bump into her
and she gives me all this stuff i have a
girlfriend kind of sort of
i didn't it wasn't worth it i didn't
have a girlfriend so i had to be later
than that
it had to be when i was going through my
[ __ ] that
she called i met her in the city i
didn't try nothing
i just i was i was a mess
this is like a breezer for me for me to
hang out with it was a breather because
i was usually hanging around around
animals
so i uh see this girl
and she's like is that you and i'm like
is that you
what is the [ __ ] coincidence
seriously and we start talking
and she goes what are you doing tonight
nothing she goes i live right under you
no i go under you [ __ ] you for the
last month
you and some girl listen to [ __ ]
prince tall hours of the night they
would just listen to prince
i'm like what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
girls let's take a quick break and tell
you about our first sponsor tushy
everyone has an ass and every ass
deserves the gift
of tushy wiping your butt with dry
toilet paper does not remove all the
[ __ ] if you got
poop on any other part of your body
would you just wipe it with dry paper
no water cleans better than dry paper my
friends thankfully now there's a sleek
bidet attachment that clips onto your
existing toilet and sprays your ass
completely clean with fresh water it's
called tushy
and it's the best thing you can do for
your butt tushy sprays directly to your
ass and removes the poop completely so
you aren't sitting on bacteria that
leads to nasty things like hemorrhoids
yeast infections utis
and just generic itchy [ __ ] and skid
marks bidets are common in the rest of
the world all right it saves you money
on toilet paper now you still use a
little
but nowhere near what you were using
before you're not going to clog your
toilets
and tushy sprays your ass with fresh
water it's not toilet water tushy
connects to the water supply behind your
toilet
to spray your dirty parts with clean
fresh water it's the same water you
brush your teeth with
all right wet wipes are worse than
toilet paper they're terrible for the
environment they cause anal fissures and
you don't want your anus
fissuring all right this thing is only
79
it's fantastic every time i go to
somebody's house that i know has a bidet
i make sure i sit when i pee
all right it's fantastic 79 and free
shipping and they have a tushy ottoman
that helps you get everything out all
right it's like a sexy tooth or a cloud
that helps you poop and that is only 69
both of those prices are really nice
here's all you got to do go to
hellotushy.com
slash honeydew you'll get 10 off your
order
and free shipping upgrading your
bathroom does not need to cost a zillion
dollars
again hellotushy.com honeydew you're
getting 10 off your order
and free shipping wash your ass
our next sponsor is upstart during these
economically turbulent times
everyone is looking for a way to feel
more financially secure so if you're
still
needlessly throwing money every month at
high interest credit card debt
it's time you checked out upstart the
revolutionary online lending platform
that knows you're more than just a
credit score
now is the time to find out how low your
upstart rate can be
to help pay off high interest credit
card debt unlike other lenders upstart
can reward you
based on your education and your job
history in the form of a smarter rate
you don't need a degree or a diploma to
apply though
upstart lets you skip going to the bank
because it's completely online they
offer loans from one thousand to fifty
thousand dollars
so you can consolidate your debt into
one easy fixed
rate payment upstart makes it fast and
simple to check your rate
since it's just a soft pull it will not
affect your credit score the hard pull
happens
if you accept your rate and proceed with
your application
the best part if the loans approved and
accepted most people get their funds the
very next business day
over 400 000 people use upstart to pay
off credit cards or meet their financial
goals free yourself from the burden
of high interest credit card debt and
get back to using your money
your way with upstart see why upstart
has a 4.9 out of 5 rating on trustpilot
and hurry to upstart.com
honeydew to find out how low your
upstart rate can be
checking your rate only takes a few
minutes
that's upstart.com honeydew
our next sponsor is from our friends at
superhero stuff you should know
if you're a comic book fan and you think
you know everything about your favorite
superheroes you can think again man
our friends at superhero stuff you
should know will put your knowledge to
the test
did you know tim burton almost made a
batman musical
or the real reason why bebop and
rocksteady weren't in ninja turtles too
or how superman almost had a love story
with his own cousin
that's disgusting but it's true this
show covers it all mixing clips with
hilarious commentary sketches
and impersonations so tune in to
superheroes stuff you should know
available on itunes spotify and youtube
now let's get back to the duke so i went
down that night
and we went on a date and
boom she was my girlfriend the next
morning we stayed all night
i ended up wrestling with her
who [ __ ] wrestles on the dates she
told me she had three brothers she used
to wrestle them she was you want to
wrestle
so we started wrestling in front of the
[ __ ] lawn she ripped my shirt i
ripped her
shirt it was tremendous and we just
started dating
and i didn't tell her what i did you
know and i was doing great at foot
locker
i was doing great at foot locker in fact
they
just had offered me paperwork for
full-time position
me and her were dating like three weeks
she did not know about the credit card
scams
i'm bringing her jewelry every other day
and flowers all bought on a fugazi
credit card
i'm taking her for lunches all like
fake [ __ ] fat credit cards
so now one day i'm at the [ __ ]
foot locker it's august
of 85. i'm in foot locker and what the
[ __ ] do you think happens
a chinese family comes in and they had
like one of those celebrations like one
of those yin yang celebrations
where they put all the money in
envelopes and put them in one big
envelope
so i'm fitting all the kids for sneakers
but i'm eyeballing the envelope
i got [ __ ] 10 g's in the bank
you know this is the [ __ ] that this is
what i said the sickness
had everything going on but that
envelope was sticking out and it would
not
[ __ ] there's a whistle on the hatch i
[ __ ] clipped the envelope i put it in
my pocket
i go into the back i ripped the envelope
open this i don't know
five grand cash i fold it i put in a
sneaker
like a size 14 orange sneaker which
nobody's gonna touch
and i take the paper and i flush it
i don't know i just had a weird feeling
i go back up there i'm talking to the
family
everything's great we go to pay and also
like oh yeah
oh yeah my what happened no and they're
talking about money
when they came into foot locker the
money was there
that had to be somebody who worked there
took it
so i'm like there was some kids and
they're like yeah their kids
those kids took it so they called the
cops they made a big deal about it
they called the cops and that's when the
jewelry chick came over
and she goes you know what a couple
weeks ago some guy came in and used a
bunch of
a credit card to get jewelry he looks
like him
and then they [ __ ] came like three
days later
it's like august 20th now 25th
and they came in to me detective sipa
was his name
okay he was he wasn't even a detective
he was a patrolman this is going to come
back to haunt you
his name was sipa something like that he
comes and he goes jose can i talk to you
guys listen
i know it was you who arrived those
chinese girls we're just waiting for the
tape to come back from the store
he goes also we've passed your picture
around
you three or four people recognize you
as the guy that ran a credit card scared
me
because it was quite an amount you ran
up i mean i was just buying jeans every
day
we're waiting on the footage from the
gas stations
bro they couldn't get me
they were doing all this [ __ ] so they
came to see me on a saturday
then they came back on sunday and
they're like listen
monday we're gonna have all the evidence
to come and arrest you
if you do this now it'll be a lot easier
on you
and i'm like guys i don't know what
you're talking about
that night i go home they [ __ ] knock
on my door that night about nine o'clock
and they go listen we're waiting for the
pant sizes to come back
and once we get the pant sizes we're
gonna make it
what wasted you and i'm like i don't
know
you know i don't know what my waste is
but once they left
i went downstairs and knocked on the
door and took her outside and go look up
this whole [ __ ] joey d [ __ ] this is
[ __ ]
my name is coco and i'm a [ __ ] thief
yeah i work at footlock but i told her
the truth
like i gotta leave i don't wanna
your sweetheart you're the first person
i've ever had in my life
that i don't wanna lie to you know i
don't wanna i'm sick of doing this [ __ ]
yeah i'm 20 something years old you're a
nice girl this [ __ ] looked at me she
goes
i'm coming with you
next morning we got up i said pick a
spot she goes san francisco
san francisco it is got to san francisco
now guess what i did
i left at 10 g it wasn't like now that
you had an atm card
and you had 10 no i left the 10 g
in boulder i had like six g's i said we
go to san francisco get the party
started with six
g's we went to the alexandria hotel it's
probably still there it's a dump
it's in that [ __ ] part of town
that's horrible i forget what they call
it in san francisco like they hate
ashbury the back in the day
down more down more there's a name for
it it's
horrible we lived there we were across
the street from a restaurant called the
hotel california
that breakfast and diners and [ __ ] we at
the alexandria
for about a week but it was too
expensive so we ended up going to the
virginian hotel
i don't know what street that was on but
this was one of those rooms where you
take a shower in the hallway
and you live in the room but you have to
share a shower with your side of the
building you go in that locket
you can put your towel down in your
clothes and you walk back to your room
real cool all the people live there
i blew to that six grand like in two
weeks
like and dinners breakfasts so i had to
go on the grind
you know i'm buying so here's what
really happened so it's 1985.
i haven't dealt with anybody cuban i
haven't spoken any spanish
and i go to san francisco we check in
the virginia hotel
i tell them to stay put i'm gonna get a
bag of wheat and i walk
down the tenderloin
that's what the area is called i walk
down there and as i'm walking
i see these black guys i'm
african-american
and i'm like i'll go ask them if they
have weed
and as i walk up to them they're
speaking spanish
and they're not just speaking any
spanish they're speaking cuban spanish
and i asked them direct guano and
they're like we all cuban there was like
60 of them on that corner
and they're just shaking down people
selling coke
selling ids so i introduced myself
i met one of the guys and i started
buying weeds from him and that's like
three or four days
they're like you speak english i'm like
yeah
like you could be a little helpful the
whole operation here
oh they didn't speak english at all no
no so
they had a bunch of [ __ ] to do that they
could do
but they didn't know you know how to do
it but just standing on that corner all
the action came to you
so i'd be on that coin off and you come
up to me and go hey man
i got 600 in travis checks i'll give you
uh 200 for 600 travelers checks
because i know i could take that to
japan town up by vanessa
with a suit on and i could charge i
could
take a hundred dollar travelers check
buy a dollar postcard and give me 99
cash
so i come ahead they're insured so
i i became mr travelers check
anybody who had travelers checks they
brought them to me anybody who stole
travelers checks
they brought them to me there was one
guy on the block that you had to pay him
his tribute every day
all i had to do was give him a bottle of
scotch he liked a certain expensive
scotch
so i gained wisconsin that let me
operate on the block
i had to pay a little vague to help out
a couple guys but it was okay
because every time i go down i had make
money i go down there with a suit
first thing i did was go to liquor store
give the old man his tribute and poodle
that was his name it boot him and he
just dropped history on his [ __ ] cuban
history
i used to talk to more time i never
forget when this mexican dude
came up to me he's like i need money and
then poodle's like talk to me in spanish
you [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] mexican sparks [ __ ] he
goes you know how many [ __ ] white
people
kicked your [ __ ] family's ass and
threw him out of he goes california
used to belong to mexico and white
people took new mexico now you want to
speak spanish go [ __ ] yourself
speak spangler whatever the [ __ ] you
want to speak english go [ __ ] yourself
when you talk to me speak spanish the
guy was just an old fountain of
but it was just a collaboration of
[ __ ] characters
and bro i was doing everything one day
i'd be doing travelers checks
one that'd be passing out counterfeit
loot it was endless
endless my girlfriend at the time wasn't
doing dick
i was bringing home the money we would
go to tad steakhouse chinese
we were living day to day like after a
while hand to mouth
so i started pouring jewelry you start
pouring
jewelry with the credit cards you buy
jewelry you pawn it
whatever there was a place called coffee
runs it was a topless coffee shop
topless coffee shop 1985.
my girlfriend at the time they would
serve you topless yeah yeah
so she just you could either be topless
behind the bar you could have a shirt on
okay whatever you want my girlfriend
kept his shirt up
so she would work it cut at whatever rot
and then i walked into a you know like i
was always trying to go to the
legit i don't want people to think that
i was always a criminal like i was
always trying to go
legit but on those days i couldn't get a
job
i had to go back to what i did best you
know
and i remember one day i went for a job
at a mexican restaurant
and i wrote the application i gave it to
the guy
the guy knows where you're from and i go
north bergen new jersey and he goes
what did your parents do for a living
like they owned the bar
and he goes well guess what my name is
jose diaz
and i'm from union city new jersey we're
like third cousins
come on my human wells and that nephew i
go no i'm manny's son
and he goes my cousin is your father's
uncle
so he goes listen bro it's great that is
me he goes i can't give you a job
but i'll get you a job at another bar
let me call my friend and wait right
here
and he got me a job so how long are you
in san francisco at this point
i'm in san francisco maybe three weeks
jesus christ
and he gets me a job at a place called
rockin robbins there's a bartender slash
doorman and i go okay
so [ __ ] it i'll be a bartender out here
so when i left him
i was when i went to the sheridan i was
part of the american bartender institute
the sheridan sent you to american bar
attending school
and you get certified to be a bartender
big [ __ ] deal you might as well drive
an uber
right so if you go to bartending school
you're a [ __ ] loser okay there's
nothing better than all the barton in
school because you find out
the true alcoholics on thursday they
would have like
mixed night like drink all the mistakes
you want for 50 cents
you just see how many people were going
there oh they show up and drink when
you're practicing
you're making singapore slings with the
wrong
[ __ ] 50 cents people don't give a [ __ ]
they're just drinking up the mistakes
they would make like a
like a pseudo bar but part of the
national
american comedy whatever it was part of
it was that
they had to hire you it was
nationwide whatever for the rest of your
life
oh okay so i could walk into an american
boxing academy
tell them my number they could go on a
computer and they have to send me out on
job auditions
i don't even know if they still exist so
i'm just walking down the street after
this interview
and i look up like american bartending
school i walk upstairs and i go hey my
name is joey diaz
i went to the school in new york they go
hold on
how are you doing john this is whatever
i have joey diaz here do you have him on
file
hold on in those days there was no
computer right yeah somebody had to go
to a file
i said yeah he graduated in february 84.
okay thank you but
we'll get you a job because in fact you
got a job that's perfect for you italian
like well no i'm cuban he goes don't say
nothing to him just tell him you're a
talent
i'll never forget this is horrible he
gives me this piece of paper and he goes
go down there they want to talk to 9 45.
now if you know anything about me i'm
gonna get there at [ __ ] nine
that's how i was raised okay so i get
there at five after nine i get there
with my suit my girlfriend goes with me
we are down to the
the money we took on the bus to get that
that's what we have we don't have a
diamond money
every dollar we have we just spent on
the bus right there
she's waiting outside i go inside
only this could happen to me now i i
didn't i
i didn't have the rocking robin's job
yet like i was going for an interview
that night later
this was my first interview of the day
and this is for a lunchtime bartender
so i go in there and i'm like the paper
says i'm looking for
all right all right
all right hello i'm here at nine o'clock
9 45.
you know the coffee's on no art
i walk a little deeper all right all
right
i keep walking and there you go
there's an office wide open
no no with the bank deposit and then
it's wide open oh that stacks of money
i'm like oh my heart's about to get
ripped off
three two
one and i go in there and i just start
taking that stack of cash
i'm putting the cash down my pockets
because i've done some bad
i'm putting it down my pockets i'm
putting it in my jackets
i take everything but i'm go i'm a
[ __ ] gavon
i go for the quarters the stacks are ten
dollar quarters
and i put them on this pocket here
because this pocket was filled with cash
so when i walk out of the office i walk
in and my jacket is twisted
this side's all heavy it's all twisted
i walk out the guy's like hey what are
you doing here i'm like
i'm looking for steve he's the steve we
got no steve here i'm art
i thought you were my 945 are going no
no no i'm not looking for a job my
friend told me to meet him here
he goes oh i'm sorry what restaurant i
go i think it's emilia's because
i think that's down the corner and i
walked out of there
and that's when i heard him go come back
and by that time i grabbed
my girlfriend and we just took off 20s
were flying out of my jacket
we're running up the [ __ ] hills of
san francisco
we finally see a bus and we get on the
[ __ ] bus and we jump on it if we get
to the back
we're like was that close she goes what
the [ __ ] just happened well let me tell
you what just happened i started giving
like
a hundred thousand quarters and i'm
taking 20s
out of every [ __ ] suitcase i got
every every package and also we counted
up i don't know
a thousand bucks we put in our pocket
she had a hundred and quarters
as i'm getting off the bus a little old
lady goes whose 20
bill is this i know it's mine but
[ __ ] it you take him for good luck
because god bless you so
and i made this call
but this is the killer from manila
when i was a kid and no offense to the
lgbt community
when i was a kid i wore a scarf like
every once in a while i would wear a
scarf and my mom would go come here
what are you rob hudson get the [ __ ]
scarf off
now my mother died in 79. i love that
your mom knew because my grandmother
denied the [ __ ] i'm like he [ __ ]
he said it my mother 79
my mother died rock didn't come out till
85.
if i call me when you're cuban you're
supposed to call me hair on the left
side mm-hmm
if you're coming on the right side
they'll call you over come here what are
you rock hudson
he's like what what the [ __ ] are you
talking about so my mother over the
years would call me different names
whenever i acted a certain way instead
of calling me gay
she'd say something what are you going
to grow up to be um
is a guy in jail that commands respect
because
he takes you and he makes you gay you
suck his dick and he [ __ ] you in the
ass
but you don't [ __ ] his ass and he don't
suck your dick
he's basically your husband and then the
cuban traditions he could smack you
bunt beach up and you got to take it
there's no one 9-1-1
there's no [ __ ] hell is for children
there's nothing you take the beat and
that's how it is
had heard this i had heard about this
did i ever see it no well guess what
it's the summer of san francisco in 85
i saw it one day i'm on the corner and
they're like [ __ ] don't
say nothing bro this is the big time
coke guy
and he came like with the cape over him
like you know like he's just flamboyant
yeah i just came back from miami i got
the good [ __ ] if you guys
want it i'm in room 131 at this hotel
down the corner on my 131 we'll rob the
guy
and they're like oh he's connected all
the way to miami he'll get shot in the
head
but he had two guys dressed up as women
that would hang out with them like with
a day old beard
women they would stuff their bras and
they would walk with them what he would
do is he'd stand on the corner opposite
us
and they'd hold the coke and you go up
to him and he'd go sell him a gram
and she collected but when one would
[ __ ] up
he'd like smack him right in public and
they would fall down the wig would fall
down
you couldn't write this [ __ ] like even
today i'm looking at this and i'm like
jesus christ what is my i'm 22
and i'm seeing a straight man beat up on
a poor gay guy that doesn't even know
he's gay like
he's caught up in a cult it was and i
saw him punch him
like one day they made a mistake i'm the
wrong cigarettes he threw a beating on
one of those [ __ ]
he was just beating like like it was
just crazy
the guy was on the floor he threw the
wig on top of him he kept kicking them
in the stomach don't you ever get me the
wrong cigarettes
that's a sign of no disrespect the guy's
bleeding from his mouth
it was just hilarious after about a week
the guy
watches me and he knows i can handle
myself
he asked me if i had a gun i told him
yeah he goes listen
i need somebody to watch my back on that
corner it's a deadly corner
so he gains my trust
i'm working for him i like the small
hundred a day
and no cocaine
i wasn't doing cocaine i wouldn't even
touch it
wouldn't even touch it but he keeps
talking about this room 131
so one day he goes to eat lunch and he
goes i'll be back in an hour
we're going to the other side of town
i go i'm going to 131 i go to 131
kick the [ __ ] dog down this is the
genius your uncle joey is
i go to 131 kick the door down
in the middle of the room is a [ __ ]
bag
i unzipped the bag
there's no coke i don't know if there
was no coke but let's just say there's
no coke
what there is is about maybe 20 grand of
american cash
damn and when i zip it back
when i zip the other zipper there's
stacks of colombian money
stacks then he had another bag that had
stacks
of columbian money stacks
i mean i don't even know how much it was
so what do you think
the guy in front of you did i took all
the colombian money
because there was so much of it in this
bag that
rivaled the american cash i go let him
keep the cash
we'll make this look like one of the gay
guys duck did it
so i'll take the colombian money so i
take the columbia money i take it to my
hotel room i go back to the corner like
nothing happened
he comes back an hour later i've been
robbed they took the colombian money
blah blah blah i'm gonna find out who it
is and put a bullet i'm like i'll do it
for you
i've been here the whole day watching
you should have sent me over to what
this would have happened if you would
have sent me with you
i'm one of those guys i'll put you
together that's why i shot my [ __ ] no
so i run home i get on the phone my
goombas and jerry's on my dog listen
rent out
the garden and they're like what i go
see what it is to rent out the garden i
gotta have at least three four million
colombia
that's gotta be at least a million
dollars i'm gonna pick it up tomorrow
and i'm gonna come home i went down to
the corner and i've got the biggest
blackest dude that hung out with the
cubans
he had to be six six two [ __ ] eighty
big black guy he goes what's up cuba i
go tomorrow
you gotta walk me to the [ __ ]
international bank
it was right across the street where
people do [ __ ] tai chi right yeah san
francisco there's a hundred people out
there
doing tai chi you got to see me at nine
o'clock i got one of my best suits on
i got sinatra on i lost you
i lost you too this summer when i got my
cuffs
i told my girlfriend i go when i come
back here we're gonna be millionaires
she's like what are you talking about
like what do you think it's in the bag
i go to upstairs big lose down there
waiting for me
he's got a weapon on him i got a weapon
on me i go listen
we're gonna go over there i got about
four mil in here
hopefully they'll give me a million
american and i'll cut you and i'll give
you
i'll give you like 10 grand and then you
have to drive me we got to figure out
how to get to the
airport i'm going back to jersey i
called all my friends in jersey
i got a million dollars i got a million
dollars
the bank opens at nine i'm there at ten
to nine
i i'm saluting the flag
what a great catch oh my god she opens
up the door
and i might tell you is your lucky day
and she goes what's going on how much do
you have to transfer i don't know
and i start taking it out in badges
and putting it out she's like hitting
that calculator
i'm hearing all these numbers and i'm
like oh and i'm looking at the black guy
i'm like bro we're [ __ ] we're living
lives we're getting barbecue today
we ain't [ __ ] around this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] hit numbers for like an hour
i'm thinking i'm playing when i'm like
you think you got enough cash back there
to pay me
yeah and she's like looking at me like
all sudden she goes to the thing and she
rips the thing around and she goes this
is what you got coming to you
it was like 390 dollars
i gave the guy a hundred dollars i
wanted to cry
i walked back to the [ __ ] thing
now i gotta go down the corner i gotta
face the [ __ ]
with the cuban guy they're all pissed
off
so this was part of the thing
but there was a guy in the building that
i kept robbing every week
at the virginian hotel together nobody's
thinking
first of all i became the best
hotel thief because i would sit in the
lobby and wait for you to check in
i had great spider-man hearing and
whenever you
check in they go go to room 311
i'd see you go up to 311 in san
francisco people go up to their rooms
get their cameras and they run right out
i would go up to the room
kick the door down take the travis
checks you know and then i'd follow
then i in my building i just followed
the mate around
and one day i found she would open the
door with the key
and leave the key in the thing i creeped
up behind her
took the key took it off not even took
it off the ring went downstairs there
was a
bodega slash [ __ ] lumber yard
downstairs
right downstairs they made me a spare
and i put it back before she even knew
it was missing that's how good it was
and i had that key and there was one old
man that was
retired he'd always sit in the lobby
downstairs i'm a bookie if you want and
he would do those
ticket slips so i would go into his
house every friday
and take like his poor little hundred
and fifty dollars from the slips and i
believe the gambling slips
i was just torturing them everybody
every week
everybody gets it when around me those
days you got it
so i'm banging them out like three weeks
in a row
but i'm also doing rule number one i'm
[ __ ] where i sleep
okay i'm starting to [ __ ] hit the
people in the building
you know like when i was friends with
the [ __ ] guy who ran the hotel and i
was friends with his wife
and we're going off to dinner and drinks
and they're telling us
we think it's the guy in room 14 that's
robbing people i'm like yeah it's
probably him
the whole time it was me there was a
little gay guy
we had
we had if you opened up your window
there was no view there was no bridge it
was another window there
another window there and another window
where you are
and it was maybe eight feet there was a
guy in that window that would put that
music on
by stevie wonder you and me
part time yeah
leave the window open he was gay and he
would just dance the part-time lover he
would put it on
over and over and over and like
oh part-time give it a
and he go part-time you man i'm getting
ready for my performance tonight
so i'm doing this [ __ ] i'm i'm torturing
the guy
i'm robbing the bookie and i'm [ __ ]
bartending i think monday i worked the
door
and i had a thursday bartending shift
and that's what i'm doing and i'm not
doing guys and i'm with the cupid's in
the daytime
i'm not doing bad but i got greedy again
one damn downstairs and these [ __ ]
guys come in they're talking german
and i don't know i wound up i don't know
i heard money
so they [ __ ] like mario they leave
and i go
right to that room i open it up i close
it
i go through the luggage i go to nothing
guess what they're at the door trying to
open
oh [ __ ] so i lock the top lock they
can't get in
and i actually go out the window to see
if i can walk the ledge
thank god i'm on the second floor but i
don't have the balls i got to go to the
ledge and i don't have the balls
so i go what am i going to do they keep
knocking that's like hotel security
who's in that was my friend and i hope
it was the door he goes what the [ __ ]
you doing hey go bart before you say
anything
i go i'm sorry i go the door was open
and i took the maid was in here i came
here to get two towels
and there was no towels and the germans
were like we're calling the police
and i go call the police i didn't take
nothing i didn't touch nothing you guys
knocked on the door and i got scared i
was just going to take some towels i go
how long am i olivia
i've been here like two months with no
problems they're like
somebody's been doing [ __ ] around here
and the cops came and i talked to the
cops out of it i'm like i've been here
for two months
i work at rockin robins i go why would i
rob somebody
i go i went to get towels and they're
like well it's true
the maid and the two cops let me go but
the germans were like
they called their embassy did they they
did they're like this is [ __ ]
if we were white you would arrest him
so they started pushing for it so the
restaurant the guy that owned the hotel
the guy that
i was friends with called my room and he
goes hey
the cops are on their way to arrest you
you might as well get out of here so me
and my girlfriend packed up
there was a back set of stairs and we
could see them walking up the stairs as
we were going down
we ran maybe two blocks and those were
buses to reno
for like tonight you go to reno five
hour drive and i remember getting on the
bus
and [ __ ] there was a arab guy in
there and he was smoking
i like what do you smoke and he goes i
get weed and i mix it with cigar
and i put hash in it and i go let me get
a hit of that
i thought i was going to [ __ ] die
so that's it you're out of san francisco
now
uh reno we basically went to reno
got off the bus walked and then came
back to san francisco
and then we just went to the airport and
i had enough money to put her on a
flight
so the plan was for her to go to boulder
go to her bank account go to my bank
account
and get me a plane ticket for me to fly
back to boulder it was gotten too hot
and
uh whatever for me so i lived in the san
francisco
airport for two days you did yeah that's
when
nobody knew right right yeah back then
nobody had an idea there was no charging
phones
everything and i remember even then that
every time you went to a bathroom a guy
would walk in
and he'd go up next to you and piss next
to you to try to look at your dick
and i remember sitting there all day
going what is this guy doing
all these flights have taken off and
he's still here
but he goes to the bathroom i go let me
see if this guy is a closet
gay guy sure enough i go to the bathroom
and i'm pissing
he comes in with me he's like two things
away and he comes in next to me he looks
at my dick i'm like you freaky
[ __ ]
i'll beat that because i was raw back
then
and uh what a great idea though god
you could have lived in an airport back
i was living in the airport you could
have just moved terminal terminal
they're not gonna follow you or figure
that out in those days they flew all
night
right three a.m fights yeah you know
there were flights to [ __ ] so they
didn't know
there was no international terminal you
could fly next to a flight that was
going to hong kong they were boarding
wow bars closed at like two then but
there were lockers at hotel at
airports and you could put your [ __ ]
things out that's right
so we went back to bold uh san francisco
uh we went back to boulder
and we basically stayed in boulder for a
week
and when i called my buddy
to tell him if i should come up he goes
i have news to tell you
you know that girl that came out here
from north park to be with me and i go
yayos
she's knocked up we'll move him back to
jersey
you could take the job well it was a
house-sitting job
it was 16 hours of work a week free rent
in snowmass village colorado
you have no idea most people would suck
a [ __ ] for that job
like you could get somebody to suck your
[ __ ]
wait a second i get to live in a [ __ ]
2 million dollar house
for free about the robbers the guy
worked for he was on the board of
directors of friday's
tgifs so he only you it was one of his
18 houses
jesus so he only came once a year
and he had a jeep and he wanted you to
use the jeep
so when he came to town everything was
run right he didn't want you in his
house
he built the house for you over the
garage that was great
it was great [ __ ] you i was living in
his master bedroom the second
night jacuzzi
skin i had the [ __ ]
i had the thing going i asked my buddy
my buddy had the job for like three
years
i go does he ever come he goes i'll call
you a week before the guy's cool
he knows what we're doing here he'll
call you a week before
paint 16 hours at work is basically
mowing the lawn in the summer and
shoveling snow in the winter
i moved in there like november of 85
and i was good i got a job at the
crestwood
at night as security at a hotel from
four to 12. i
picked people up at the airport and
checked them in and
then i got a job at a video place called
commander video
in snowmass village just my love for
movies
i met michael douglas there i met robin
williams there
nice nice sydney what are you there
uh it was great first month i think it
took me a month to start snorting
that's when you finally got back in the
end and the oh new year's and by
about a year i stayed clean for a year
and i think it was like either that new
year's
or two days after the new year i snored
a little bit and i was like okay i have
respect for it now
so i would snort once a week
once a week on saturdays me and a
girlfriend we got a package
[ __ ] sniff each other's [ __ ]
[ __ ] suck and
yeah that was it that was what you did
when you were that age you don't get
coked up you know
give you those half-hour blow jobs and
you eat the ass for an hour and
you tie them up now i wasn't even into
tying people up back then i was just a
square
but that's all it was it was very
innocent then
a guy that i'm still friends with
calls me one day the blue [ __ ] goes hey
i'm in denver you mind if i show up
there's something i got to show you
and he comes up his name is danny b
he's called into my podcast a thousand
times
he shows up to aspen and he shows me his
coke
he tells me how he buys coke and he
re-rocks it
and he could sell it to you for eight
hundred dollars so i asked around
they wanted eighteen hundred dollars for
an ounce
he would give it to me for eight even if
i
sold it for 16 i made an 800
profit golfer but i cut it
got it but i cut it so
i started borrowing money like i would
go to you and go
give me five 3 for two days
what are you talking about because i
already had the coke salt
the coke was so good it was salt it was
already
gone i would when i'd borrow money from
you i had
already had the coke salt so all i had
to do was bring the coke back get the
money and give it to you
so that's what i was doing i would take
a flight back to jersey every wednesday
and come back with a quarter key nine
ounces
i was beaten up to local drug dealers
they couldn't even compete with me i was
like seven ounces
15 to 1500 and i would still make 700
pounds plus i
cut it and then i was selling grams for
80.
damn and i'd sell them for 40. i put a
little rock in the package
and a little bit of chunk i'd still cut
it and i had a dude carl hall
selling for me he would go out at night
because i didn't go out then
he would go out and come back he would
sell two ounces a night
in [ __ ] bundles it was it was just
crazy
but i was snorting [ __ ] everything
then i figured out
why am i i'm flying back there with coke
and i'm flying back there with nothing
and i'm bringing back coke and and i go
why don't we
[ __ ] build this business up
so i started bringing back pounds of
mushrooms
and they went nuts yeah because in my
hometown
it was all micro diet acid so you get
top dollar for mushrooms
but then a friend of mine asked me
something that was crazy
can you get guns and i go let me check
and i went down to a gun store and i go
i want to buy a gun they're like
give us your id pick one
that was it then huh so i picked
i was buying guns from this guy
and i i got it where i'd go to you
and i knew the guns were 400 new
i could get six and a quarter but
i got the same holster that don johnson
used
and the two clips here was called the
spider or something
you're not going to believe this i would
land
i would take the 7 a.m flight out of
aspen
which connected got you to denver at 8
00 a.m
which gave you got you on the 9 40
flight from
denver to newark it arrived in newark
like i wanted to
i would walk off the plane with
a suitcase filled with guns
two bags of mushrooms underwear socks
and a toothbrush
just in case you looked in there locked
the suitcase and i'll be going there
all the guns were in boxes they were
brand new
i would get to my friend danny b's house
and he'd have like eight guys today how
you doing and they would get ready i put
the whole strong with the gun
and i'd come out like dancing and they'd
go crazy
eight hundred we'll give them nine nine
fifty
you're modeling this [ __ ] hysterical
why would you i'd sell it
and tell them to lay down lay the [ __ ]
down lay the
[ __ ] up i'm sorry i'm [ __ ] with you
and there we go oh you're scared
and then one time i brought a pound of
[ __ ] mushrooms
okay i put a pound of mushrooms danny
was crazy at the time danny b
was crazy i mean our whole worlds were
crazy
i'll never forget walking to danny b's
house with the guns
and like him going listen i'm gonna be
busy for an hour
is there something you could do i'm like
me and your cousin go get a sandwich
and i remember coming back home and he's
on the phone
talking to a drug dealer he's got his
safe
it's a huge safe it's like a three foot
four foot safe that's wide open and
there was
money on the top shelf and the rest was
little bottles of decadent
steroids okay because he also sold
steroids it was just rows and rows of
steroids
and on top of the safe was a mirror with
a little mound of coke on
it and three lines cut out and he's
talking
i'm watching this from the couch and
he's talking to whoever he's talking to
he's like yeah i know
man i know he hold on ma
get the shot ready and he's like i know
i know how it is man yeah
he would talk to his mama ma get the
shot ready
i didn't know what was going on and he'd
go listen i gotta call you back
my mom's gonna shoot me all right he
would go into the room
and he would go ma you're ready and she
would go yeah and he would bend over do
a line of coke and then she would shoot
him with the steroids come on
you can't write this [ __ ] and i can have
this [ __ ]
he's sleeping now his love
with steroids but here's what gets
better and leo tell you
he had a younger brother not the
sharpest guy a little [ __ ]
never had a chance at life
god just never gave a full brain i
forget what his name was
lee what was the guy's name that went to
jail
what was his name
we tried to get him a job this guy's
career started as a 14 year old he would
put fishing lines
down night depository boxes people make
deposits at night
and one night he fished a bank deposit
bag
with 14 grand damn he took a cab to
kennedy airport
and he tipped the cab driver a lot of
bill
and he took a flight to hawaii and they
caught him in hawaii
they did so they put him back in jail
hilarious
they recognized him by him giving a
halal tip
to the cab driver gary
gary gary so gary
was about maybe 13 one day
it's like a year before he thinks about
the fish line thing
get there and i'd get there
and i'd like they go what'd you bring us
and i
put weed on the table ah you know
let me see the guns oh and then i put
mushrooms there was a bag of mushrooms
at this time that'd be an ounce or two
and they were dry and i put them on top
of the table
and we were in the bedroom it was me
danny and his partner
danny no tommy
i don't know who was in the kitchen but
i'm hearing council
i like somebody's eating
like danny what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
is that
we go out there it's the 13 year old
brother
eating the mushroom [ __ ] snacks
i mean he's like
danny's like gary what the [ __ ] you
doing
those are cyber sailing mushrooms and
he's like what's a mushroom
he goes obviously you're gonna [ __ ]
see how many of those things are genie
was i don't know
he ate like [ __ ] a quarter of a bag
he's 13 years old
me and danny we all go out drinking we
go snork
coke we walk in at four o'clock we pull
up to the house and then he goes
[ __ ] my house is dark i wonder what's
going on in there
he goes whip out your guns something's
going something's not right
we [ __ ] go for the guns because we
all carry guns
we open up the door we walk up the
stairs we turn the light on
and there's this 13 year old brother in
the living room
sitting that by himself with his wife's
wife
he's rubbing his legs and he goes what
i'm not tripping that was
it that was it we [ __ ] died we're
like ah
so believe it or not ryan sickler i was
[ __ ] making money so even if i [ __ ]
up i'd make money
right and at one point i was up like 60
grand
that's the only time i've ever been a
winner in my life like by
september of 86
i was up like 60 grand under my bed
and then something happened it just
snapped like
i could not have any success and i
started
just flying over there to get the coke
and snort it with my friends
me this dude mike and my girlfriend at
the time
by that time i had another kato he
wasn't chinese though it was keith corn
they just called him cato
i had call i had this whole army and we
were just
selling bare minimums and then
the people who i was dealing against
this is one of the wildest stories i'll
ever tell you
this is like one of the wildest things
but this is just to let you know
where i was as a 23 year old man
there was a couple other drug deals they
blew up a drug dealer in aspen
his name is dan grabo they blew him up
he got arrested he had like eight
million dollars on them in cash
damn they didn't find no drugs they were
going to arrest them for
tax evasion and 12 days
before you can look this stuff up if you
want to december
12 1986 as he got in his car
he went to start the jeep and a pipe
bomb oh they really blew him up yeah
they weren't playing games
so that network was scrambling
that network was scrambling and here i
am behind that back
pulling 1500 ounces cutting there
and then i'm taking their street action
from because i had a couple dealers
that i don't like going out and selling
on my belly it's called selling drugs on
your belly i didn't like it
going to a bar and having a package you
can't go it's like being in a stolen car
so they did it i gave them like i said
listen just give me the principal
you can make all the profit but i need
this [ __ ] out of my house
because i'll snort it if not i remember
i had a bomb
at that time the big thing was bazookas
you take a cup like this
you put three fingers of water in there
you throw a gram of coke
and three tents of baking soda and you
put in the microwave oven
for 26 seconds once you get addicted to
the
bing once you hit bing you take it out
and there'll be little white pebbles in
there you take the white pebbles out you
let them dry
and you put them you cut them up with a
razor blade you take a joint
with regular paper roll up the joint and
then take that cocaine
and sprinkle it into the joint that pure
cocaine you roll it
then you get a lighter you melt the
[ __ ] coke into the urethra
you spark that up that's a bazooka and
they called it
cocoa puffs right in baltimore in
colombia they would take the nicotine
out yeah
and put coke and smoke with nicotine we
went on a roll with that [ __ ] once i
took over
our neighborhood we went on a roll and
then we were just
getting the wii we ran out of rolling
papers one night
and i had one of those not glass bongs
but the other type of that other
material like plexiglass yeah
we smoked so many bazookas that the bond
collapsed like tower number two
it just kept going down and down we woke
up it was like a bong for a [ __ ]
it just collapsed that's how much heat
we put to it with the [ __ ] blowtorch
so i wanted a complete
and total disrespectful tear
like i really the end of 86 really at
the end of
86 and then what really kicked it open
was
i was supposed to go to my girlfriend's
brother's
wedding she left on a wednesday
and all my cocaine foundings i had found
this coke that they called
like i forget what they called it like a
white powder ma
coke or something sea of pearl they had
a name for it
i happened to get two ounces of it was
pink
it was going for 2 000 an ounce the guy
owed me a favor
gave it to me for like 14. i took two
ounces and i was going to save him for
the wedding
so i had this friend who was an
electrician
i brought the two answers to his house
he didn't get high and i go put these
and you're
safe i do not want to touch them for a
month i didn't touch them
the wedding was saturday i was scheduled
to leave
on friday night at six o'clock i went to
pick up the coke at one
i went home i got dressed i packed a bag
i did one line of coke
and i missed the wedding oh i sat in
there for three [ __ ] days with my dog
i was so paranoid i wouldn't let the dog
out to pee
he would just sit there like when can i
pee and i'm like you're in no danger so
you better hold on to it cause you ain't
peeing and you ain't [ __ ] that's how
bad i was
from friday at one to like
monday i didn't stop snoring i called
the cops on myself
like four times that weekend this burger
was on my property
this paranoid it was it was terrible i
was in a horrible place
she came back like tuesday or wednesday
she was three-quarters heartbroken and
she was like listen i don't know
i could keep doing this i mean this
isn't really a life this
is just we're living like animals you
know we're still in coke and i'm like
okay
she goes i want to go back to school
there's things that i want to do in my
school
i want to be a snort and coke i'm
meeting your ass every day what do you
need school for you to do it's cool
before you learn to go up your ski and
snorting [ __ ] suck and you know
i could feel i was just wearing on it
and then it was until
thanksgiving that everything fell apart
i went to city market and i ordered a
turkey
and i have like a i thought it was tony
montana i invited like 10 people over
for
she got a bunch of [ __ ] to cook and
invite people over
and that wednesday before thanksgiving
those were the days where i would just
come to you and go sick like can i talk
to you for a second what are you doing
tonight
you're like no i'm staying home i'm
going to do me a favor i'll give you 200
go stay at that hotel let me get your
house for the night
don't come back and i would sit in your
house
because i thought the cops wouldn't be
watching me there
and i would just watch your tv watch hbo
and jerk off and do coke by myself
and i got a batch of coke that i went to
cato's house and i stayed there from
that night
and i missed thanksgiving holy [ __ ]
but i came i walked in on friday and she
was packed
she was done and she goes i have to go
this is not a way to live and i go here
right
i'll go with you but i gotta borrow
money i didn't have any money left
i went to all the 60 and oh damn so this
kid owned mama maria's pizza anymore he
was dying to be a gangster
i had like two of those guys i never
borrowed from because i was just setting
them up
like every week i tell them you know
[ __ ]
ryan cycle made 20 grand with me [ __ ]
when can i get a piece of that soon
don't worry about it yeah
once ryan falls out let's get rid of
ryan
yeah yeah i went right to that idiot
mama maria's pizza i took him for like
five g's damn
he goes when do i get it back you get
back in fact i'm gonna give you a bonus
i'm gonna give you 12-5 on sunday so i
had that five i went to some other kid
borrowed
two for 27 and i had a coke dealer check
today the chick lives here and i like we
haven't connected
but people told me she's here and she's
probably forgotten about what i did for
but i did the perfect scam on it
i bought this weed that was fugazi weed
the weed looked like it was weed from
today but it was
that [ __ ] 1980 around back then it
looked good but it didn't get you high
so i sprayed water on it to make it
weigh a pound
between you and i man everybody listens
oh my god
between you and i i owe this lady
i forget what her name is it comes to me
from time to time
i i think her latest name was vermont or
something like that
i went and she's like you better have my
[ __ ] 20 grand at that time i owed
her 20. i owed this other deal damn
that's a lot though
holy [ __ ] oh i held this other dealer 45
grand yes holy [ __ ] and i owed him
her his partner that was a female
30 large you know that's a hundred and i
had a crush on her
and i knew how to soften her up she was
hotter than [ __ ]
i remember she was on a date she broke
up with a boyfriend a boy from mr psycho
i still remember her name she wanted a
date she went to get in her car and the
boyfriend was hiding under the car
he grabbed it by their ankle and broke a
[ __ ] ankle damn
got out and beat the [ __ ] out of the guy
so it was well known not to even ask her
on a date
so we had become friends everybody was
scared of her i owed her like 30 large
the cops were watching me i had the dea
watching me which is official the cops
were watching me because a guy
was snorting coke and aspen and his wife
was the accountant for the department of
for the town of aspen she was skinning
me money off the top
so her and her husband could snort coke
and she got caught
and part of a pleiadia agreement was to
go
after other drugs okay
turn in people so somebody turned me on
to him
and he would come over and go every time
can we do business outside
i'm like why what these guys are cops
so i i played them i played them for
like a month i kept my house clean
i found the tap on my phone and those
days you broke into your phone box
and there would be a little wire and it
would say who was tapping it
and then one day really yeah one day i
had a friend of mine come over
and it was a two-car garage i had him
pull into my garage
and then i left i went into the car
dressed as him with his car
yeah and i took off and i took the long
route and went behind the house and you
could see the guys in the telescope
and i beeped at them they froze there
was nothing they could do
but my house was clean i had no coke in
the house
i had nothing so that
friday after thanksgiving
we got all our [ __ ] together that was
worth it
we had a little mazda 2 door we packed
it
i went to that lady's house
and i gave her i said listen i know i
owe you twenty thousand
but you know my friend ryan sickler
right yeah
oh he's getting married and he needs all
he did it
i know you're not going to give it to me
on the arm did i ask you
did i [ __ ] ask you what i brought you
is collateral is a pound of the sweetest
weed you've ever seen
she looks like she's like oh my god
do you think he'll trade me for it i go
no let me go give him the [ __ ]
half ounce of coke and when i come back
what would you be willing to give for
that and she goes tell him i'll give him
another half ounce i go
fine let me go get them i wasn't coming
back
never i got in that [ __ ] car with
that half ounce of coke
and we just left and all night long
there was a car following us
the car followed us for about two hours
you know how many hotels
we checked into that night three
it was a four-hour drive to denver we
took them to three hotels
because we go into a hotel do a line of
coke
we get so paranoid we'd have to leave
out it was terrible it was just
it was a horrible horrible horrible time
for me and this is the end of 86 now 86
ends with us
in boulder we're clean
she went back to live with her mother i
moved in with four [ __ ] dirt bags
and uh i got a job i ended the
year working at a car wash drawing cars
that's where we're gonna stop good
that's another [ __ ] great
one more story one more okay so when i'm
living with those
uh those three idiots i'm 10 12 14.
yeah 10 12 14 makes me laugh
i'm dating the girl next to the girl
downstairs now
[ __ ] the girl next door with the big
tits
[ __ ] a [ __ ] roommate yeah i'm dating
the girl next door i love the girl next
door she's
beautiful she's blonde she's got pretty
eyes
those two little [ __ ] desert tramps
they were just desert tramps one [ __ ]
the other one's roommate
[ __ ] blocking me with a tits out it was
a disgusting situation for a guy like me
so he comes to me one day and he goes
hey
can i talk to you in spanish she doesn't
listen man she she made moves on me
i go look i'll do your singers but i'm
scared i never did it before i go how
old are you
he was like 21 like you never got your
[ __ ] ping to suck before right so
something happens he went over there
and started like dating her and like a
week later he copped out of two
of me like i heard what you did over
there
you did not supposed to do that i'm like
who the [ __ ] does this guy think he is
so one day i'm running out of ideas or
something because i'm torturing the
cato i'm torturing the [ __ ] white
dude
and i look in this mexican's room that
our door is shed but there was no lock
so i could just open it and i looked
through his room
it's like a picture this is the piece of
[ __ ] i was there was a picture of his
mother and his grandmother it was like
coco
you know his pictures of all his family
members
and there was a towel in the closet with
like a little jaw of vaseline i go
the [ __ ] can i pick up the towel on this
hundred dollar bills
i took those to go
that night he knocks on my door and he's
like
can i talk to you because somebody stole
200 from my room and i'm dying inside
i'm like
really and he goes you've see my hands
i work in the plantation all day
for that two hundred dollars of if you
know who did it please give it back to
me i'm like
okay you ain't never seen that you
i was just nuts man i was just [ __ ]
nuts
oh man well as always i was
86 and i'm sure we left that
86. if i didn't get back in time
if my flight was delayed in newark
and i didn't get back in time i would
have to spend the night
at the denver airport and catch the next
first flight
to aspen airways that must have happened
three times do you know
all three times i hooked up with either
a chick or a guy at the airport
and we snorted coke all night i would
put the coke in a locker
and take out like eight balls at a time
i would spend like 80 000
quarters because that quarters
no one like you dude i met a guy from a
record label once he was like
[ __ ] everybody's record manager i'm
feeding him with coke
he's like call me if you're in l.a we
became
friends i mean it was just oh man it was
such a sur i was buying the guns like
the [ __ ] i was doing i had a cop on my
payroll
that came over to my house one day i was
talking to him about guns
and something came up he's like you do
coke i'm like yeah you want some and i
was giving him the pure [ __ ]
you know how many nights he knocked on
my door on his shifter
on a shift oh [ __ ] up like i mean his
eyes were
he's like you guys can borrow some more
from me [ __ ] yeah
he wouldn't pull nobody over he was a
picking county sheriff and they drove
sobs
and i remember him pulling up to my
house there are sobs that's right
colorado
he was he would he would come up to me
and his eyes were bulging out of his
head
and he would go on this another rock man
so he started giving me all the
guns he would confiscate jesus christ
dude
all right this is what we're gonna do
we're gonna end here and we're gonna
pick up
on january 1987
when we continue next time so now
i'll talk about the patreon because i'm
not really getting great
i don't know what's going on with the
book deal social media is getting very
evil
i wanted to do something different
little videos i want a little bit more
interpersonality plus i want a
commitment
the guy up at the rochester club and
said do you ever notice when you do a
show
people don't pay for tickets they're a
rowdy or [ __ ] audience that's right
i the podcast is still free i'm not that
i'm not an indian giver
the podcast is still free this is
different content i want to create
and there's two people in particular
that i want to help out there's a direct
to do
and the graphic designer dude liam may
do the podcast that's cool there
this is something for me and two other
dudes i used to shoot all those joy
karate videos
and regular videos i want to come up
with a new character like an uncle joey
type character that gives advice to the
youth every week
something funny i don't give a [ __ ] it's
something outside the box
that's why i charge you one dollar
four quarters one dollar i just need
one dollar if i wanted to rape you guys
i could rape you
i'm looking for one dollar of your
commitment because i know you're not
gonna [ __ ]
send back negative [ __ ] at me and call
me a fat [ __ ]
and tell me that yeah they're the die
hards the loyal fans you guys are loyal
fans
but the other thing i love that you're
doing i want to say this too because
what what i've learned about patreon is
it's a dollar but you can give more if
you want to get more
you feel like i do five dollars you can
get more if you want to get more but i
do five bucks you get video you get
audio it's
it's a new episode it's not like here's
the rest of this or here's that you know
it's a full new thing with uh this is a
podcast good for you the podcast has
always been for free
you know what i might do i see that when
you take a
like if i mean you do a podcast somebody
will take a eight minute bid out of this
and they'll get eight million hits why
aren't we doing that
right so we'll call them podcast bits
where i just
interview somebody for 11 minutes and
put it on patreon it's great
there's so many different things to do
on patreon well look stand-up's gone
right now we
have to figure out how to make something
that's right
and i'm not in business to rip i know
what you're paying for patreons or
whatever i'm not in business
to rip nobody's heart out i just want a
community
that you don't open up the page and it's
like
you know nick cannon's right
trending or yeah everything that's not
this has nothing to do with this has to
do with us that's right so
patreon.com joey diaz a dollar or give
whatever the [ __ ] you want to give
next week i got the chance to shoot
videos so i'll start
great videos that's it well thank you
everything coming on we'll start with
january 87. thank you to jimmy's seafood
thank you jen for the masks uh
and as always ryan sickler.com ryan
cigar on all social media i'll talk to
you all next week
so